Holiday bender,
oh Jesus Louisa's.
Are you allowed to say that anymore?
Eventually you won't be allowed to say
anything.
Duncan Trussell,
but you know you can do.
You'd say whatever the fuck you want.
If you're using a Tang cell phone,
that sounds like a Mitch Hedberg
punchline.
A tank cell phone thing is a one of our
favorite sponsors because we've had
friends that use it and they actually
enjoy it and they do save money.
It's a way to use a high level cell
phone service sprint.
They buy time on the sprint network and
but they give it to you at a better
rate.
They give it to you in a way that's much
more flexible.
They make it so you can cancel anytime
you want.
They offer you the highest of high end
mobile devices and when you go over to
ting,
according to them,
I have done no independent study of my
own.
I should just preface this advertisement
with that.
Ninety eight percent of people would
save money with Ting.
They all offer the most high end android
phones that are available like the
Samsung Galaxy note three,
which is what I have pretty dope
malicious,
or if you're more reasonable person
perhaps you would go with like the htc
one or the galaxy s four.
Galaxy has for us probably the perfect
size phone,
but I'm a glutton so I needed that big
fat,
stupid,
extra large screen sun,
uh,
but do it through ting.
Go to [inaudible] dot [inaudible] dot
com and save yourself 25 bucks.
You could also bring your nexus five
over to tank if you already have a nexus
five.
If you're a sprint customer,
you can get a Sim card from them in
order to bring your device over to ting.
Just go to the bottom of the devices
page.
Ting doesn't sell the nexus five yet,
but you can purchase one from the Google
play store and easily bring it over to
ting.
They also accept the iphone four and
four s from sprint.
Super easy way to get cell phone service
from a company that's just not trying to
bullshit you and not trying to include
all sorts of unnecessary charges that
you can get from a lot of cell phone
companies.
I feel like I just listened to a Philip
K,
Dick expert because like if you think
about if you jumped back five years,
if someone heard what you just said,
it would just.
No one would know what you're talking
about.
It's true,
right?
You use 17 words that are all new that
are just new words.
Cell phone provider.
Your device.
It's not a phone.
It's device.
Early termination fees.
Yeah.
Etfs,
they call them in the business.
The business you have to.
Big Business Rogan.ting.com.
We're also brought to you finally buy on
it.com.
This is a light week folks.
We don't want to borden you borden.
You burn
you lizzy board board in burden at the
same time.
That's borden.
You.
That's a new word.
That's why can't we have a new word when
someone's burdening you and they're
boring.
Bored.
Boredom.
Me,
we made up the word monotony,
but not to me for a book.
That's a good one.
Monogamy and monotony together.
Yeah,
that's a good one.
I like that.
I just read that boredom is if
considered in Buddhism a form
of anger that boredom is one of the
widows boredom itself or the expression
of boredom.
Boredom.
Boredom is in the boredom.
Falls under the anger umbrella actually
because it's a resistance.
Boredom is a,
uh,
you're resisting what's happening in the
moment.
Cue The music was talking about this
fucked on a commercial.
Use a codeword Rogan save 10 percent.
I'll finding all supplements.
I do too.
I love it too.
I don't want to talk to you.
Don't do any commercials.
Experience podcast by night.
All Day.
Sorry.
Sweet.
Sweet on it.
I think everybody knows about you by now
on a Dotcom O,
n,
n I t,
t boredom.
You were saying Duncan trussell is a
form of anger.
I was listening to this Jack Kornfield
audio book and he was saying that
boredom.
That ain't that boredom is part is it
comes from anger because it's resistance
to what is when you're bored.
You're resisting what's happening and
that's a form of anger.
It's in the family of anger.
Tell it to the dude.
Been in solitary confinement for five
years.
I'd be fucking pissed you.
Yeah.
I think that guy needs to stretch out
that definition a bit,
a little bit.
Reasonable boredom,
you know?
Have you ever taken an ear beating from
somebody that's not anger,
that's your board?
Oh,
it's totally real,
but it's always resistance.
Like if you're experiencing boredom,
you're resisting what's happening.
You don't want to be there.
That's what border but isn't resistance
sometimes.
Exactly the right thing to be doing
mean.
There's a passivity at the heart of some
Buddhist scholarship that I find
irritating.
That is something I used to think and I
disagree with that now because I think
that you.
You definitely.
It's not like suddenly you're like,
I'm just going to be in every situation
that I'm in.
It's just that instead of being in a
situation experiencing that,
if what you're saying is the idea that
the only thing that will motivate people
to change is pain and the idea is like,
no,
that's an illusion.
That's not what you need.
You don't need pain too.
If you.
If I'm in a house that's on fire,
I'm going to get out of the house before
the fire burns me.
I don't need a feeling,
a physical experience of pain and
boredom,
desire,
anger,
all of these things.
If you really feel them,
it's not the greatest feeling.
It's never a great feeling.
It's always either a forum.
It's like an itchiness or a sense of
just wanting to get out of where you're
at,
but if you really want to get out of
where you're at,
the best thing to do is to calm yourself
so you can get into a nice tranquil
state and then get out of the situation.
You don't need the addition of a kind of
psychic heartburn,
which is what boredom is.
I'm full of psychic heartburn.
The worst when people are giving me your
beatings,
I know it can be doing something more
pleasurable.
I,
I just,
I can't take it.
I,
yeah,
and that's,
that is a,
um,
that's exactly like the idea is if we,
if you can,
if we can dissolve that,
that sense of resistance,
then it doesn't mean that you're going
to be getting ear beatings from now
until infinity.
It's just when the ir beatings come,
you only be experiencing the pain of the
ear beatings and not the internal
mirroring of that pain as you
desperately try to get out of the
situation by saying you have to use the
bathroom for the ninth time.
And some people at the comedy store
think I have like a serious bladder
issue because
I gotTa Piss.
Dude,
can you excuse me?
I gotTa Piss you guys.
Do you know who Juliet b?
No,
she's French actors.
Beautiful French actors know.
Uh,
you've seen her.
You would know the name.
I've seen these in the unbearable
lightness of being.
It's one of those names that I've never
actually heard set out loud.
Be impeccable franchise.
Beautiful.
Isn't that beautiful the way it's been
now?
But no,
I don't think I've ever see.
See,
I've only seen it written down.
Yeah.
Well anyway,
I met her in this weird story.
I was speaking at this event like a Ted
style event in Toronto.
It's called idea city.
And uh,
the day I was supposed to speak Deepak
Chopra was there,
all these big shots.
The day I was supposed to speak,
I told my wife because soda,
I'm just going to sleep in today.
Just let me sleep.
You go ahead,
go to listen to the lectures,
whatever.
And I'm gonna Hang.
Okay,
fine.
So she goes down.
Ten minutes later she's back up from the
room.
She says Julia had been,
she's downstairs having breakfast and
she wants to meet you like Julia B.
No,
she wants to meet me.
Are you kidding?
No,
not really.
So I get out of bed and brush my teeth
or anything.
I called downstairs and I immediately
sense that she doesn't really want to
meet me,
which she wants to do is sleep with my
wife and my wife is completely
misinterpreted everything and I'm
barging in on this thing.
And,
and I started talking to her about the
unbearable lightness of being this great
film.
She was in based on an amazing book and
how this book sort of changed my life
because it got me this job and all this
weird shit and as I'm telling the story,
she's reaches over.
She's looking right at me.
She reaches over and she just touches
her blackberry and 30 seconds later it
starts ringing and she picks it up and
she goes,
oh,
I'm sorry.
I have to.
Wow.
I was like,
ah,
yeah.
Okay.
I,
you know,
fine.
Right.
I'm not offended whenever I have done
the same thing,
but I was really done the same thing
though.
Oh yeah.
I wouldn't have said like,
I got to go pee for the ninth time.
This hour with Dunkin's doesn't seem
like you're just throwing you under the
bus.
No,
no.
Just saying it's the same phenomenon.
And I was on the other end of it and it
was just at a different level.
It's escape hatches built in boring
conversation because I know I'm going to
be talking to this dummy,
so why is that?
Not In the.
I'm sure it existed three,
but you need like a satellite,
a three button click or like five clicks
or taps out up with the volume and
starts calling you in 30 seconds you
would know or you just get busted
immediately.
Everyone know like,
wait a minute.
What was that?
Did you don't touch your phone when I'm
talking to you?
Right?
Ultimately could never really,
truly be successful is if it became
successful.
People know and it wouldn't work anymore
and you have to stop.
Wait a minute,
okay.
You program it yourself that way.
It's a different pattern all the time.
Nobody would know or a key word that
Siri hears you say eventually triggers.
Eventually funds are going to be so
smart that it's going to not want to get
an ear beating.
Like it's gonna.
It's gonna.
Call you and be like,
dude,
we gotta get Outta here,
man.
This is horrible.
Oh,
I thought you meant from,
you know the phone.
His cell phone will be like,
dude,
what did you think we were saying?
That's what I thought would be smart
enough to be tired of listening to your
stupid shit that that's what I feel like
with the NSA.
It's whoever's monitoring what they
fucking deserve.
Every fucking morning they wake up and
like,
look at a garden and then go to watch
him jerk off fucking porn all day again.
Are you seriously idiot?
The idea that there is one person that's
actually watching everyone
mathematically
possible.
The idea is that their store,
but it is a dirty thing to do,
to just store everyone's everything in
some database somewhere.
It's a dirty thing to do.
Tell people that you're doing it too.
It promotes this massive state of
paranoia almost instantaneously because
you're doing it without letting anybody
know that you're doing it and then
you're denying its existence and it's
ultimately proved to be true.
All of those things are very bad for
public confidence and all of those
things.
When,
when,
when they take place,
what's.
What's gross about it is that you did
it.
You had the possibility to do it.
That's technological.
That's unavoidable,
but you did it.
You wouldn't just copied everybody's
everything.
It's stored it and then he had denied it
when it came out,
like in principle.
It's a fascinating trend because it's a
trend of a disillusion of boundaries.
The connection between a person and an
idea,
a person,
a piece of information is becoming more
and more instantaneous.
Whether it's a google search with it's.
I think that this is just a subtle
victim of this overlying trend in
technology of bringing people and
information closer and closer together.
It's,
oh,
it's almost unavoidable,
but it just sucks that it had to be done
by the people that are supposedly
protecting us,
supposedly watching over us like,
wait a minute,
how old are you,
Joe?
You don't believe they're protecting us
and watching over time,
but,
but who does?
But it's the narrative is the narrative
is the day propel that rent,
that narrative comes up every four
years.
It comes up in various speeches that
when the president gives speeches and
people will pretend that drops news and
CNN legs are heroes.
They pretend that these are legitimate.
We were all on the mainstream news
sources,
so you almost have to address it in a
way.
You almost have to at least pay it some
service just to diffuse it.
Did you see that?
The NSA logo,
that
flying around fucking.
They're like not trying to pretend
they're protecting us.
They're like,
no.
Put a evil octopus devouring Earth Vr
logo.
Fuck you.
Snowden.
Yeah.
It's a fucking demon.
Octupus cracking from space to space
cracking.
Oh,
could you imagine if there were space
crackings?
Could you imagine if we had been all
this time we had never been found,
but the universe is literally like an
ocean and it just takes time for one of
those fucking flying fish to to realize,
oh,
I can eat this one.
Just success up.
Socking things out of the atmosphere.
We're like a speck of plankton.
We find out we're actually in a notion
dark matter.
It's just water.
It's just the we're.
We're in some strange state and that's
the way emotions.
Yeah,
I mean there,
there are less believable scenarios.
There's not real water,
but there's dark matter water.
Nothing is beyond our reach.
Jesus Christ.
That's weird.
That's weird,
but it may,
maybe it's fake.
Is that phony?
Because that went flying all over the
place and made me think I.
I just seems like I like it because
people at the NSA or like,
you know what,
let's just fuck with a stoner.
Let's do it.
They're already paranoid.
Let's make him super fucking parents
already.
A bunch of shit
gives fuel to the super paranoid.
Like the fucking I on the dollar bill.
All that weird Egyptian iconography,
Shit.
All that.
The,
the,
the mason stuff,
all that weirdness,
man.
Yeah.
E pluribus unum.
There's a lot of weirdness on,
on just money itself
and it's hilarious because all,
I don't know what it is,
but having been on your podcast enough
times and like rambled about free
masons,
inevitably some loon will send a message
or post something on my board that's
like a,
are you a pawn of the new World Order
Dunkin?
It's like,
I know I'm not upon of the new world
order,
but it's funny to think,
Oh wow,
I what that Weirdo is doing to me.
I'm doing to the government,
you know,
like it's all just this endless state of
like,
we'll never figure it out.
You'll never figure out who's behind the
whole thing,
but it is funny how easily people will
assemble Ed Arctic bits of information
like that shit with Terence Mckenna
being in the fucking CIA.
Are you kidding me,
man?
Really?
Terence Mckenna,
Mushroom Mckenna,
God of mushrooms.
The CIA is like,
let's,
let's use this guy as well.
Our spokesperson.
Well,
you know,
there was a cia guy going around helping
with distribution of LSD.
Without a doubt.
There's been a lot of people that were
in the psychedelic community.
Their problem is that yawns statements
about Mckenna have been dismissed by
everyone who's listened to the
recordings that has half a brain that he
was joking.
It was a sense of humor.
He was talking about the alien
intelligence and the mushroom and the
mushroom recruiting him as a
spokesperson.
That's what he was talking about and I,
I hadn't heard that is yawns take on.
It is literal law.
Yawns take on the recruiting for the
FBI,
which look,
I don't know.
You don't know,
but if you have to look at is what is
most likely?
Well,
if that's your only piece of evidence.
If I listened to that,
most likely I would say that he's joking
around.
He's talking about the mushroom,
but yon is one of those weird dudes that
has been like researching this shit for.
Did he say anything about Gordon Wasson?
He knows.
Yeah,
because he was in the CIA.
Yeah.
There were some connection with Gordon
is hiring people that smoke dmt and
talked about aliens.
I will.
I'll send you my resume.
I'll fax my resume to you.
I think the CIA like seaworld.
It's not 100 percent evil.
You know,
this is probably a bunch of people
there.
The train dolphins that really loved
dolphins.
It does it.
Does it stop the institution from being
able to.
Just because a few of the people that
are involved in it.
You guys know about John Lilly,
right?
Sure.
Yeah.
Well that's the.
Was He in the course?
It was,
but he was into hallucinogens and
Dolphin.
The connection.
Yeah.
We have the documents.
You know,
I don't know if yawns right or wrong,
you know,
quite honestly,
I don't think he does either,
I think,
but if you look at it,
most likely,
most likely that's not what was going
on.
Most likely.
Terence Mckenna was a hippie and he uses
also one point,
uh,
in his argument for saying that he was
in trouble with the FBI and they got out
of trouble like seemingly out of
nowhere,
but if that's all documented by dentists
and Qa and terrence,
they talked in depth about him turning
himself in and them offering him some
sort of a plea deal.
Uh,
Dennis sent me the email.
I could read it,
but I don't have his permission.
But yeah,
I don't think Transport Canada was in
the fucking CIA know also is the data or
bi or whatever the fuck they can use you
without you ever even knowing you're
being used.
Yeah,
sure.
Like a lot of peace corps people.
Well,
I think we're used as a listener.
Anybody,
and I really mean this.
Anybody who listens to Mckenna talk
about cei talk about psychedelics.
Anybody who listens to that and is not
intrigued is a fucking idiot and I think
that includes people that are in the
CIA.
People are in the FBI just because
people were square on paper and just
because you know they're supposed to
abide by the schedule.
One rules of the United States
government,
human beings are individuals and
individuals have autonomy,
a certain amount of it,
at least when it comes to their own
thoughts and you listen to a guy like
Terence Mckenna and you go,
well,
who's side do I take?
The evil overlord that I fucking work
for,
that pays my bills and couldn't give two
fucks about me or this psychedelic bard
who might be onto about a million things
that I've never even considered once
might be correct about this idea that
he's preaching about psychedelic drugs
being the very why human beings
exist in the first place.
In our lack of use of them today is one
of the reasons why we're so disconnected
from nature.
Like we just shot into space and then we
lost our cord that connects us.
We lost whatever the connection was to
how we got there.
Sounds ridiculous when it comes from a
guy like me,
but when you hear Mckenna talk about it
and he's talking about climatological
changes and about how the hominids moved
out of the trees to experiment with new
food sources as the rain forest receded
into grasslands,
I mean this is well documented shit and
then also the positive attributes of
Psilocybin,
the increase in visual acuity,
the fact that it makes them Hornier so
you'd get like monkeys that were Horny,
they could see better if they ate these
mushrooms and then the transcendent
experience that it comes from them and
like all those together can't be
ignored.
I mean the idea that it's not considered
primarily as the reason why we're not
monkeys anymore.
It's only because enough people or too
many people are ignorant about it and
because the propaganda involving these
drugs,
it's been so strong that whether or not
you believe that it's had any positive
input influence on anybody.
You know,
you can't deny that that experience is
fucking mind blowing.
Like legitimately fucking mind blowing
to the point where if you've haven't had
it,
you wouldn't believe it's possible and
then when you do have it,
the world is never the same again
because you believe anything's possible.
Fuck Buddy.
Ignore that.
How could you ignore that as a
possibility for cognitive enhancement
when you're looking at a primate,
a thinking thing that discovers this
mind altering insanely powerful drug
that happens to grow the fuck everywhere
in shit.
Yeah.
Shit.
And they're following these.
The following.
These monkeys clearly tipping over cow
patties and pulling out worms.
They're experimenting with food sources
constantly.
If this stuff was there and it was.
If they ate it and they did,
of course that's the X.
There's a doubling of the human brain
size over 2 million years at directly
coincides with this receiving of the
rain forest in the grassland and
experimenting with all these new foods,
new foods or what do you think that it
listens to that and I think it's very
interesting.
I,
you know,
having studied this kind of stuff for
awhile,
I'm very hesitant to say that it,
but I would certain because everything
ends up being multilingual,
urea and out of other shit,
and I'll tell you,
here's a really interesting,
here's a,
well that's the whole man,
the hunter thing so far,
but here's a really interesting theory
that I don't hear spoken about much that
sort of corresponds to this a little
bit.
Same time period of course,
uh,
people were running under hot sun
because of the receding forests.
It was savannah and one of the ways of
hunting is to run the deer down,
right?
Because we can persist much further than
they can.
They're faster,
but only over 200 meters.
And then they get tired.
They don't sweat.
Right,
exactly.
Yeah.
So,
so these dudes are running.
It's hot,
lots
of Sun.
The brain gets overheated and so
evolutionary pressure is on creating
redundancy in the neural networks of the
brain as a,
as a,
as a sort of insurance policy against
overheating.
Right?
And so what happens is we develop all
this surplus in neural tissue that then
gets wired into one thing as opposed to
it's like having a spare tire and
suddenly your car has now five wheels,
you know what I mean?
It like the,
the,
the evolution took advantage of this
thing that was made for something else,
which is a very well known concept in
evolution.
It's called a spandrel.
It's something that seems like it was
designed to do that,
but in fact it's a byproduct of
something else.
And ultimately of course,
every result is a combination of things
coming together and creating.
This is one thing that we think of as
like,
oh,
human beings,
human consciousness,
the evolved human consciousness.
But when you think about all the
possible factors that came into play and
all the different things that must have
happened and selective breeding and how
people figured out who to mate with and
how.
Well,
that's David Eick.
David,
I,
uh,
I would,
I would like to have him on the podcast,
but I think apparently he doesn't like
talking about that lizard thing anymore.
Talking about the reptilian things moved
on.
Feels like it's a distraction from what?
I don't know.
I mean maybe he's abandoned the idea,
but I've heard he got mad at somebody
for talking about.
I think it was like a Jesse Ventura
show.
Do you know?
Do you know you get.
Might've got mad at Jesse Ventura
because I think that was it.
I think they got an argument.
Jesse Ventura was calling him off raw
hide.
Yeah,
I saw that.
I saw that episode.
He like ambushes m and then he like
really lets him have it and then it was
well uncomfortable.
You know,
there's a fucking,
there's a,
there's a good point there.
You know when you,
when you say something like someone's a
Reptilian,
like everything else that you say,
I have to go,
come on man.
The fucking you get you.
You.
You're going to show the first instance
of something that's able to change back
and forth.
By the way,
not just,
Oh really?
Oh,
that's the idea.
It's not just like you're a caterpillar,
your butterfly know your counterpart,
your butterfly,
your batter fly you back to a
caterpillar to a butterfly.
That's what they're saying.
They're saying that you can change back
and forth like there's nothing that
does.
That is nothing.
You've got to have a video.
You got to have something.
You gotta you gotTa.
Show me some fossils.
You can't just go around saying people
are reptiles,
man,
you know you just can't do that because
then that means you're thinking sucks
and I can't trust you to be the guy that
talk.
But snakes used to be a huge,
huge problem for us.
Right?
Isn't that why there's like.
I mean,
yeah,
but it's not.
Back then it was like a big fucking.
Now snakes are a problem,
but you're not going to run into a snake
too.
When I'm getting coffee to starbucks,
I'm not going to like snakes.
Not gonna bite
pre,
pre.
If more than 5 million years ago,
snakes must've been such a problem that
humans,
chimps,
and Bonobos,
infants all recoil at an image of a
snake.
Even if Eskimos who were never going to
see a snake,
right?
Eskimo kids will freak out if you show
them a picture of a snake.
That reptilian thing is like a
reflection of this,
like this weird residual neuro,
a horror story that got imprinted into
our brains.
And so now when people like David Eick
or just trying to make evil or
categorize evil are in the book of
Genesis.
What,
what,
what's the evil thing?
It's the serpent.
It's just a symbol that's supposed to
embody ultimate evil.
It seems like.
Well,
every animal besides us is compassion.
Less they are compassionate,
especially if other animals,
they just don't.
It's not a part of the,
well,
not every animal other than those
dolphins,
chimps and Bonobos,
intelligent ones,
intelligent fox.
Come on,
you've met this dog,
right?
You've ever seen foxes were people,
uh,
they start living in the woods near
foxes and the foxes eventually gained a
friendship and then they become like
their pets.
It's very common for foxes to do that
and to become almost like dogs and
become like really friendly with people.
But you know,
ultimately what makes us human.
One of the big things that makes us
human is this insane level of
understanding we have for what we are
and what our places and constantly
recognizing constantly either coming up
with some way to justify it and some
self righteous position to take or
coming up with some way to try to fix
the damage we've done or coming up with
some where you're just trying to at
least understand it,
but all those things are going on all at
the same time.
Looking for validation is my idea right
about this anger at this guy in traffic.
It's all this big sea of shit that goes
on at the same time.
So to compare that to anything else that
exists,
it's like it's one of the weirdest
animals that we've ever seen ever.
And it's us.
Yeah.
It's the weirdest shit ever.
If we didn't exist,
if we like found us objectively found us
and started analyzing our impact on our
environment,
this ultimately colossally catastrophic
effect of us even existing on everything
else around us.
Just to nihilists the ocean of fish to
the point where tuner coming back,
radiated,
and there's fucking a massive.
Of garbage in the middle of the ocean
and the numbers of fish are down so
radically that people are worrying that
within 100 years there won't be any wild
fish in the ocean anymore.
Within another hundred years we've
cleaned out getting wiped out all over
the light.
If we watched us from afar,
objectively,
we would be like,
oh my God,
this outbreak,
this is insane.
Planetary athletes,
but let's get that shit off of their
super eight super eight,
just athlete's foot.
There's no lamisil.
It's going to get rid of people,
but we do spread.
You know what I mean?
You could,
if you looked at it historically,
you'd see these little sores and then
rashes spreading out.
You
know,
we're about to take over.
We're about to eat the host.
It's like before humans,
Planet Earth,
some disgusting.
Other people should have worn a condom.
Yeah.
Humans is herpes.
Well maybe so,
you know,
or maybe we got offloaded or something
or you know,
maybe it's just some.
Something that was on a craft.
So what did Mckenna say about this?
Right?
Because it,
along with the theory you were talking
about earlier,
he's got the,
the,
the mushroom spores going through the
outer space because they absorb cosmic
rays and there they can last forever.
That to me,
that's one of the more compelling parts
of that whole thesis.
He's got,
well allegedly
also the chemical composition of
silicide in the first place.
So aside been,
which is very closely related to a euro
trip transmitters,
dimethyltryptamine.
It's actually the,
I don't,
I'm not,
I'm going to butcher the pronunciation,
but it's something like for Fox,
for Ole oxy and,
and dimethyltryptamine.
So it is literally like the same
compound as a human neurotransmitter and
it's mixed in with something else.
And this,
uh,
this phosphorus in the four positions
for Fox for a lock,
see whatever the fuck it is.
It's the only compound like that on the
planet.
And they don't,
they don't know what the origins of it
was.
They don't know where it came from.
It doesn't mean that it couldn't have
been just a unique fungus.
Fungus is in and of themselves are
incredibly fascinating and closer to
human than they are to plant funguses or
weird.
I mean there,
there are a strange sort of Karma free
life form there.
It just doesn't hurt anybody and just
free shit literally eats shit and exists
in shit
and isn't that and attacking really
attacking you or are you just had 30
hitch.
You're a dirty bitch,
found a good spot to live,
but you can call me whatever you want,
but that is definitely attacking.
It's to encourage cleanliness and
encourage you to wash your balls.
Balls we will grow and itchy tag does
God's way.
Well,
I think it's much more,
much more
that there is no good or bad when it
comes to the natural kingdom,
you know that's much more of what it is.
Even though it's Karma free.
It's like the idea that it exists on
your balls and it drives you crazy.
It might be bad for you,
but ultimately in the universe just sort
of balances out.
Know I met this.
You can have a little itchy balls so
that it can live.
He got like pets on you.
That's what you're saying like is it
charity you should let because otherwise
you're murdering your pets.
It's like those guys in India who were a
filter over their mouth so they don't
accidentally inhale and insect.
They there.
The Jane's though.
Yeah,
they killing anything,
so I don't know what they would do about
junket.
Fascinating,
isn't it?
It's an interesting discussion.
I met a guy.
You're talking about balancing out.
I met a really interesting guy in
Mozambique last week and had dinner with
them.
He
has a thesis that each life has just
like you know,
the,
the conservation of energy in the
universe and energy's never made,
created nor destroyed everything
balances out in the end.
Right?
So his thing was each life has a
balanced amount of suffering and
pleasure and the more you suffer,
the more pleasure you'll get somewhere
else and that these things always equal
to zero.
And our great mistake as a civilization
is thinking we can increase the amount
of pleasure without compensating,
without having an increased amount of
suffering as well.
And so we're running around chasing that
pleasure without realizing that we're
also accumulating and creating
that makes sense to me,
man,
because the people that I know that have
the hardest time keeping it together
emotionally are people that don't work
out.
I don't know if it's a coincidence,
but the people that I know that have the
hardest time emotionally are people that
don't work out,
and the people that I know that do
workout,
especially the ones that work out hard,
they expelled these big giant bursts of
energy where your body's like almost
dying.
You're heaving,
your heart's pounding,
your chest.
You're barely able to lift this,
this piece of metal up again,
your Bailey able to jump on this box
again,
you're barely able to.
And by putting yourself in that intense
form of stress,
it makes regular life more peaceful.
It's the Yin and the Yang.
You do see that
when,
when professional athletes are being
interviewed,
like NBA Dudes,
they all seem
so the highest flow,
those guys are highest fuck.
Those guys get high.
They uh,
they actually keep marijuana off there
or they did for a long time off their
drug list of the things that get tested
because they all like to play stone.
Okay.
That's cool.
Hell yeah.
I mean,
what's more fun than being a giant?
Throwing a bouncy ball around some
polished arena.
That's a blast when you're high.
I think marijuana,
yeah.
Gives you a certain sensitivity to
things,
to things like it gives you a certain
sensitivity to art.
Like the art that you make gives you a
certain sensitivity to physical
movements.
Like a lot of guys love to do Jujitsu.
Can I throw something out here?
Sure.
And when you get really high,
do you kind of see things like become a
little more orangy?
Is that happened to,
you know,
because that does happen to me.
Like when I get really high things
seemed to take on a,
like a basket ball orange 10.
It's like that same kind of like the
rose tinted glasses higher.
You get inside,
you're scaring me.
Just sit across the table from Duncan
[inaudible] Duncan.
Normally you start getting high about
4:00
PM and then the sun starts going down
and everything gets golden.
That's the sunset and dunking.
Well,
yeah,
but I,
I definitely got high before four PM
orange.
You get.
Well this whole room is already.
Maybe that's just shifted the light.
Well,
you're near your near this orange and
you're also near the orange of the.
I remember when I was in high school
getting into conversation with someone I
was,
whether it was really stoned.
I'm like,
you see like orange dots everywhere.
Must've shit gets crazy.
I thought he was my friend.
Now everyone's crazy.
You ever.
You ever have a friend go crazy on you?
Yeah.
I've had friends that like legitimately
lost their mind.
I can't talk to them anymore.
Like,
like you would talk to them about events
and his version of events were just
like,
so not what actually happened.
Hailey.
Oh,
this is the person that's lost their
marbles.
Yeah.
It happens.
You can temporarily lose your marbles
permanently.
Agent or permanently.
Yeah,
but I think that like,
I mean,
yes permanently.
Of course there's like,
no,
I'm not saying through psychedelics
either.
I know what you mean.
Just saying people that just can't keep
it together anymore and for whatever
reason,
whether it's a combination of life,
stress and biological situation,
whatever the fuck they got going on,
you know,
uniquely in their own brain.
But some people just all of a sudden not
there anymore.
Not keeping it together too.
They think they're keeping it together
sometimes.
Yeah.
I mean there's broad,
broad range,
right?
There's all kinds of.
Yeah,
it sucks man.
People,
the brain is an organ and it
malfunctions and sometimes he'd go nuts
and that's stigmatized for it,
which really sucks because if you like,
because that just adds to the problem.
Like if you,
you know,
you see somebody in a cast and you're
like,
oh,
what happened to your arm?
And they'll tell you,
oh,
you know,
whatever.
I fell down.
But you,
you talked to someone who's been
hospitalized for a few weeks and they
tell you I had to go to the hospital.
I had a nervous breakdown.
I went crazy shit.
My pants during my dog through a window.
You'll want,
you want to be compassionate,
but there's some part of you that's
like,
oh,
now this is a crazy person.
It's like it's just something happened.
The operating system temporarily crashed
and quite often I think that can be a
very good thing.
I think that having your,
your personality or your ego or crash
can often mean that you were trying to
be somebody that you aren't and some
people invest so much energy,
so much energy into trying to find him.
Yeah,
they just want to be something.
You know,
they,
they it since they were a kid there,
mother was telling them,
you should be like this,
and then they try to be like this and
they hold up this thing.
They're always working to hold up this
giant tail feather in their arms,
start shaking and that they can't hold
it up and that's when they have like
anger outbursts are suddenly like their
friends are like you.
You turned into someone that I've never
met.
I don't even know who that is.
It's like,
no,
that is.
You met them.
You met underneath the tail feather the
seeding.
See the anger and disappointment and
sadness,
they that you met,
that thing that they're trying to avoid
by looking up at this mask,
they're holding up to the world,
but that fucking ceiling see of
disappointment,
anger and horror and sadness.
That's where it's at,
man.
You got to go into that thing and for
some people,
the only way they can go into that is by
having a full scale nervous breakdown
because then they can have permission to
dive into that,
into that awful vortex of darkness
because underneath that vortex of
darkness is paradise.
Underneath that,
that's love and happiness and joy and
connection and tranquility and all that
stuff and everyone thinks that the way
to get to that point is by avoiding this
awful black forest that surrounds the
garden of Eden,
which is inside everybody.
It's inside everybody.
It's there,
it's there and it doesn't matter.
You know you can work out and that will
definitely give you a temporarily
temporary good feeling,
but until you address the internal
structures that you haven't
acknowledged,
you're always going to go back to that
place where you find yourself morose and
depressed and angry,
and you don't know why.
You always go back to that place until
you sit with the sadness inside of you.
You have to do that.
What you're describing is coming out of
the closet.
Yeah,
for a lot of people,
that is what it is,
man.
It's coming out of the closet and
there's a lot of closets.
There's not just the gay closet.
There's all kinds of closet.
There's the artists closet.
Some people are fucking accountants.
They're wearing suits and their ties on
tight and they're fucking organized and
disciplined,
but inside they're probably painters.
They probably want to fucking paint.
They want to paint Dayglo mountains down
at the beach.
That's what they really are,
but their daddy or their mommy wanted
them to be a good little businessman,
so they became this thing that's the
opposite of what they are.
This is the verse in the Bhagavad Gita.
God,
forgive me because I've quoted it way
too many times,
but it's.
It's better to be an honest street
sweeper than a dishonest king.
It's better to be a happy guy brushing
fucking leafs up the street than it is
to be some zillionaire who inside is
dying or numb or miserable.
Mostly Numb,
numbs the word.
Most people are just
not.
As long as these people can quantify on
paper,
I still have a x million dollar home.
My car still cost x thousand dollars.
This suit is an ex suit.
I am still ahead.
I am not going to abandon all these
things.
As long as they don't see through the
bullshit with the game,
they think they're winning.
They have.
Yeah.
It's almost like you have to fall to.
Really.
That's what you got to appreciate those
moments when it all falls apart on you
because that means you've got an
opportunity to try it again.
This let's take a new fresh perspective.
This is a cool thing that at this
retreat I went to,
this Guy Jack Cornfield said,
which I really loved.
What a great name,
by the way.
Yeah,
with a k,
not a c,
Jack Kornfield,
mortal Kombat,
k Jack Cornfield.
But he,
uh,
he's really cool man.
But he was cool with the kids.
He's with our cat,
like the cigarettes and corny now.
This guy was awesome and he was,
one of the things he talked about is in
some religious tradition how they like
hold the scriptures a rabbi,
like had his students hold the
scriptures over their heart and when
they were memorizing them and they would
say,
why do we do this?
And he said so that when your
heartbreaks they'll fall in.
And it's a beautiful idea,
which is that heartbreak is actually
your ego cracking in the moment that
cracks.
You're in the experience of truth and
when you're in the experience of truth,
that's when you can really become who
you are.
But,
but to get to who you are,
it's like when you know,
when a bone heals the wrong way,
like that's what a lot of people's
entire personality is.
It's like
bone that grew the wrong way and that
needs a fucking,
a snap or a crack.
You know,
we,
you get that through to,
you need that,
that initial fucking thing,
and it's a beautiful analogy and that
hurts.
It hurts,
but we're paying avoiding creatures,
so we think that,
so we're always running away from this
pain,
but the problem is as we're running away
from pain,
we're still exactly in pain.
It's basically like being on fire and
running away from water.
You're just running away from the water
because
for some,
I don't know,
that's a stupid analogy actually for
great.
Up until that,
a lot of great points.
It's true.
You know,
there's the monster in the dark and the
faster you run,
the more likely you are to run into
something that's actually going to hurt
you as opposed to turning around and
saying,
Oh fuck,
there is no monster monster.
You know,
but you're never gonna know that until
you stop and turn around.
In some cases people don't have the
discipline or the assistance or the
balls to stop and turn around so they
have to trip over something and then
there's like,
oh yeah,
that's a classic story.
Classic story of someone hiding a secret
and going completely out of control
because of the pressure of hiding that.
Right.
Like that's the Ted Haggerty who's the
secretly gay guy who's preaching against
gay people.
Ted Haggard,
Colorado.
Yeah.
That was snorting meth off his gay
lovers.
Yeah.
Was just going so far the other way.
He just so off the rails.
Crazy himself.
He's by himself.
He was a guy who likes to snort math off
of Cox,
the do a little math and he likes to.
Well,
there's a few Cox,
but I would say he wasn't being himself.
What I would say is that his,
his behavior was so extreme because he
was seeking balance between that and the
other bullshit in his life.
Whereas if he weren't living that,
he'd be right in the middle.
Right?
Yeah.
Well,
but to get to the middle,
you know,
the way to get to the middle weirdly is
whatever the behavior is that you're
doing that you are so horrified about
and terrified of sometimes.
They're really weird ideas.
This is something that I liked that
Rhonda says,
which is like,
if you don't feel like meditating,
don't meditate.
Don't force it.
Don't impose this on yourself.
Keep doing the thing you're doing that's
upsetting you so much.
Have the balls to keep doing the fucking
thing that you're doing.
Keep doing it.
Society is going to tell you,
don't be like this.
Stop being like this.
You have to change.
That's what your parents always say.
The idea is like,
no,
sink into what you are right now.
Just be that thing.
Stop resisting exactly where you are
right now is perfect and that's a hard
truth to grasp because you think right
away you think,
yeah.
What about fucking Jeffrey Dahmer?
Is he perfect?
Well,
what about the leopard?
When you're seeing a leopard rip apart a
creature?
Is that thing per.
Is that a perfect moment?
I think the lumbered fucks them and
kills them,
but you know what?
Ducks do.
Ducks or necrophilia acts.
Are they fucking evil creatures?
We think they are.
Well yeah,
they are made that Phil Robertson Guy,
very famous person,
because he invented a call for grant and
now poor gay people have to hear that a
man's anus is not as good as a woman's
vagina.
Can you imagine if you made the choice
for a man's anus and you hear this
fucking bearded Fashionista with his
camera on the Bandana?
It's absolutely fascinating.
It's so weird.
I never thought of that big bearded
Christian Bible sling and Fashionista,
and he tells you that your choice was
incorrect and in fact the woman's vagina
is the better choice.
The man's anus.
I mean,
come on guys,
but how can you say that if you haven't
experienced it?
Maybe.
Yeah,
I think he has.
Again,
the balance theory.
I think he's so outspoken on that issue,
like most of these homophobes are
because they're home jerking off to gay
porn,
you know,
otherwise you just don't give a shit.
It just doesn't actually matter.
Right?
Know,
it doesn't come up in a gq interview to
duff thing,
right?
It's like,
Duh.
Already if you really care.
If people are gay,
the care the two guys love each other
and why are you against love?
You only like love if it's a man and a
woman like,
fuck man.
Really?
Yeah.
If you're talking about men's anuses in
Gq side,
you maybe you've got some issues to
think about.
Shouldn't we be talking about ducks?
Ducks?
Isn't that your whole shit?
Shoot ducks all the time.
Right?
That's your thing.
Let's talk about murdering ducks.
Yeah.
Why?
You got to talk about men talking about
asshole quality.
Dragging this in.
The blood sex sucks.
Penises or a corkscrew shaped the
wonders of nature.
Evil Nature.
Such a cunt and just such.
You're going to fuck and you're going to
keep it in there too.
How about that?
It turns into a route and you know why?
You know why dogs stay stuck together
when they have a bone?
No,
it's uh,
the,
the head of the dogs.
Penis blows up like a ball and it just
gives.
The females can hold it so he can't get
the ball out and it takes time for the
ball to go down.
So we can actually get it back out.
That's why they're stuck.
What does that help?
Anything?
Well,
most most penises have bone.
I figured what the baculum.
I think we're so lucky.
We're very unusual that we do not have a
penis bone.
If we had like a rhino horn that never
got tired,
it would.
It would be so many people that you'd
have to climb over people to get where
you wanted to go.
We would have to figure out a way to
carry our own shit with us at all times.
It would be really rude and then we
would have to meet in shit depositing
spots and places where you get food and
he'd just be crawling over and people
just fucking along the way with their
random.
Never stopped on fracture.
What about that?
Well,
that can happen.
Guys get broken dicks all the time.
It bends badly.
It actually starts bleeding and they
have to go to the hospital
and get it repaired.
If you have like a big,
strong crazy girl,
like a volleyball player,
perhaps you don't let her get on top.
It's very important.
Have a really strong woman like you
gotta.
Be careful in sports.
Is that all right?
No,
no,
no.
Those girls was too strong in the legs.
Were strong in the ass and legs because
they could squeeze to tight yoga
churches to grow with.
Generate too much force if.
Because if she gets on topic,
she's going crazy.
Some of them will be crazy.
So a small volleyball
players.
Okay.
You gotTa make sure you always keep an
under hook.
No matter what.
He'd been under a.
You want to under hook and you want to
control her hip so never let it go to
because if she just one of those mad dog
get riders that just wants to pretend
she's at the Rodeo.
She could break your dick man.
Especially a big girl.
Girls Stout bones make you a strong
child.
See,
this is the stuff they don't tell you
about this on Fox News.
Stand in the truth.
He doesn't say this and you should be
saying this.
Did you see,
um,
public service announcement?
Did you see a Lee camp?
Do you know who lee campus now he's a
standup comic.
Who was on Fox News and they were
talking about something and he goes,
he just goes,
can I just ask you a question?
He goes,
what is Fox News?
this is just a parade of ignorance.
It's just a festival of propaganda.
Yeah.
I'm not sure I might've switched the
parade and festival,
but those are pretty much paraphrasing
his words here.
It will play it here.
Kind of fun.
Can I just ask a question?
Sure.
What?
What is Fox News?
It's just a parade of propaganda and it.
It's just that it's just a festival of
ignorance.
What a million people are dead and Iraq.
Come on.
This is ridiculous.
What's the point of this?
This is insane.
Go outside.
Go,
go.
Well,
robots malfunctioning.
Listen to the girls.
You can get more worried about that.
Thanks.
Watch this though.
It gets great.
Alright.
We're also talking about Captain Kirk
this morning,
Saturday morning.
Like some fun.
Greg,
you.
We're having some fun.
Yeah.
Look who just beamed aboard right now?
The ladies from the Star Ship
Enterprise.
Hello.
Welcome their friend bones.
You know him as Dr Mccoy just wrote a
new book on Captain Kirk and the way he
was able to woo beautiful one in like
this.
It's all coming up.
He
proved his point is that it's almost
like it's scripted.
It's almost like simulation theory is
true and we're.
We're living in a Goddamn Coen brothers
movie.
Yeah,
it does seem like that,
doesn't it?
It really does.
It's beautiful there.
I think there's something beautiful
about that.
It does feel like there's like a
narrative at work here and the only way
you can live that fake life as if it's
fake.
The actual,
you know,
this,
this puritanical ideal.
They've held up.
It's not natural and they haven't been
really living in any way they've been
pretending to be living,
if be freaks in this sort of a rebound,
sort of a way to balance everything out.
And I think that ultimately that's being
exposed over and,
and over and over again
to the point where it's not going to be
a viable option anymore.
Like powdered wigs aren't a viable
option.
You can't wear a fucking powdered wig,
you know,
and you can't pretend you're this,
Rick Santorum,
guy that you know,
just as a good man who believes in the
Bible and doesn't want to see gaze,
get married,
doesn't want to ruin the institution of
marriage with homosexual activity that's
been shunned upon in the Bible and
you're like,
oh,
fucking crime money.
What's going on?
Really what's going on behind the scenes
with you cat?
What is in your head,
man?
I keep waiting for it to get to that
point where anybody who's got a big
problem with homosexuality is by default
admitting to their own homosexual life,
but I've been waiting 30 years for
America to go,
come on,
this is too silly to be real.
Ronald Reagan,
are you kidding?
That guy was such a joke,
but you know,
he's St Ronald and the seeds he planted
30 years ago.
Even then,
even then,
there was a lot for him,
but do you remember the criticism though
is pretty open.
There was a lot of people that didn't
like it.
I remember when he was not enough that
he didn't win 49 out of 50 states in
Israel election.
Oh,
well listen man,
I'm not saying that.
You know,
he didn't dominate the vast majority of
the,
you know,
mean there was a lot of idiots back
then,
but the difference between the way
people look at them now and the way
people looked at him then now it's
almost all glowing when people talk
about ringing.
I hardly ever hear any criticism.
Yeah.
You don't hear about Iran Contra and
Nicaragua and El Salvador and Oliver
Oliver North Oliver and all that
craziness and you know.
Yeah,
but my point,
my point is that this idea that suddenly
we're going to wake up and realize how
ridiculous it is and it's Rick Santorum
is too ridiculous to be real fucking.
What's her name?
Sarah Pailin.
You know,
I am amazed that how flexible the
reality muscles seems to be that people
are willing to accept this stuff that
Frank Zappa was laughing about 40 years
ago.
I wonder if they are accepting it
though.
I wonder.
I think that you watch these shows and F
and it creates the illusion of
acceptance,
but then if you if anywhere on the
internet or do you just see this
constant rebellion against that kind of
square,
mainstream,
homophobic,
angry personality,
but you watch Fox News and yeah,
you watch Fox News.
Are you watching anything on TV and it's
an illusion.
You know,
you watch the commercials,
everything's as big illusion.
You watch the commercials and it's like
people go in and buy a car and make it
seems normal.
It seems totally normal that people are
going in to get deeply in debt to the
banks.
That all seems incredibly normal,
but then more and more on the Internet
you see like people rebelling against
this and showing how the bankers like
the whole system is this fucked up thing
and emerging things like bitcoin which
are like slowly moving the energy away
from it.
I don't know.
I didn't know what you mean.
I don't think it's going to be a sudden
thing.
I think it's going to be more like a.
just a gradual shift is people just stop
watching TV.
That's,
that's going to happen.
People are just going to,
you know,
I drive down the street billboards for
fucking like Amazon.com
shows,
you know,
like billboards for shows that aren't
really controlled by these big Netflix.
Netflix.
Yeah.
But isn't
just another big network.
I mean,
you know,
it doesn't matter if it's a network or
it's an international conglomerate or
whatever it is.
It's big money.
It is,
but you're right.
But that's just the idea.
The reality is it's not that.
Yeah,
but it's not.
It's not right.
Because the media is a very different
thing.
The media where you talking about
television,
you're talking about a very hard thing
to get into the medium you're talking
about.
You're talking about an incredibly easy
for you to get into literally open to
almost anyone with an internet
connection.
You can make a youtube video.
It doesn't cost you a goddamn dime.
You have a laptop that has a camera on
it,
you talk into it,
you can make a youtube video that,
yeah,
that's a big change.
That's not just a big change.
That might be the biggest change in
human history.
It might be the biggest change in some
monkey to mushroom.
Certainly since the printing press,
the printing press was a major for sure.
Giant similar in the sense that it,
it took the power of communication away
from very few and gave it to a lot more.
Right.
So we're in that sort of.
One of the more fascinating things about
this is that there,
you know,
even if Amazon does,
but something online,
it's no better than justine who has,
you know,
45 fucking billion,
right?
Followers and she,
every video she'd put people like that
that just became famous through the
Internet.
Jenna marbles is another one,
right?
She,
she's got like millions and millions and
millions of hits.
Okay.
Yeah.
Here's what it is.
Here's what it is because I,
I've just been reading sheldrake's new
book science set free and he talks about
morphic resonance or something and I
know you have some.
I think you've,
you're skeptical about sheldrake,
but it's like when you've just have tv,
TV is a tuning fork and when there was
no internet and it was just tv and it
was a depiction of here's what a family
looks like,
here's what people tend to.
It's a corporation saying here's what
people do when they're healthy and that
creates a tuning fork effect,
which is like if you're watching it
enough,
you're going to either resonate with or
are in feel like,
yes,
I'm doing great.
I have a wife and a house and a car and
a job and that's great.
I'm in tune with what everyone else is
doing,
but that's an illusion.
That's never been what everyone else is
doing.
It's just what massive conglomerates are
sending out there either in the form of
hypnotic content that keeps you glued to
your seat.
As you watch corporations try to get you
in debt to buy cars.
You know,
it's,
it's generally,
it's just,
it's the whole thing is just,
uh,
a tuning all of society in a way that
society maybe isn't meant to be tuned at
all.
And so with the Internet,
now you have all these different smaller
tuning forks,
you know,
your podcast is a tuning fork.
People tune in to the stuff that you
talk about and the different people that
you bring on the podcast,
send out information that causes new
kind of tuning to start happening.
So that's why when you watch like
Huckabee,
you'd really feel like you're like
listening to somebody sing off key
because you're not resonating or not
resonating.
You've been tuned into a whole different
thing,
which is what the Internet,
I think one of the major things the
Internet has done,
you know,
you get these communities,
Reddit,
you can get tuned into the reddit
frequency quite easily where suddenly it
all just starts making sense.
And that is why the,
you know,
the duck dynasty guy or any of these
Weirdos who are,
um,
who are just ultimately just angry
people.
That's why they seem so fucking crazy.
Or they play angry people on TV.
All right?
Because I think a lot of these people
aren't even politics.
Dynasty guy.
The Duck Dynasty guy has been given
speeches like that for years that these
biblical retreats and stuff,
he's been doing that for.
This video is real stick.
He's not fire and brimstone God fearing
Christian man who was living on the
wrong side of the law and Jesus at one
point in time and then turned it all
around and wants to let everybody know
about the evils of sin.
He's an old dummy.
That's what he is.
He's an old dominant loved name for him.
He's an old dummy to probably just one
time,
sucked a dick and liked it.
Way Too much of someone sucked his dick
and it's his favorite moment.
It looks back on his childhood and he's
turned it into,
you know,
career.
I bet he was hunting ducks when it
happened.
I bet he was hiring that duck blind.
They're all liquored up in the moonshine
and ducks.
I bet.
Right when he came into like some guy's
mouth years ago,
out in the out in the swamps,
he saw what the call it,
a duck black duck and combined pleasure
and shame mixed inside of me.
He's like,
I'm just going to kill jobs from now on
and never think about this.
She didn't see shit.
Your Mother didn't see shit.
Your father didn't see shit if you
imagined.
That's really what it was.
All.
It was just a duck psalm.
Get his dick sucked by a guy and he's
like,
fuck that.
It didn't happen.
He to kill ducks.
I think that something like that happen,
man.
It's something like that happen,
but you know man,
like what you do with,
you know,
sex at dawn creates a resonance where
it's like,
it's a,
it's a shame reliever.
It's a shame.
Reduce your man because your book,
I think it has been.
It's such a compassionate book for
people who are stuck in monogamous
relationships and feel guilty about the
fact that they are attracted to other
people and I like that.
Guilt used to be a normal guilt that was
actually considered like,
oh,
something must be going wrong with your
relationship.
If you're thinking about fucking other
people and your book make shows like,
no,
actually that's just nature happening
through you.
You don't have to feel guilty about it
or like something's off balance in you.
It's just completely normal.
It doesn't mean you have to go and fuck
other people,
but at least now you don't have to feel
like I must not love her anymore or she
must not love me anymore.
What's that have to do with fucking
ducks,
country music songs.
That's the glue,
the glue that connects
fucking ducks and in the sadness you
have for not wanting to be monogamous
group keeps it all together.
Glue that holds the.
That's why you need to listen to Phil
Robertson and uh,
that,
that God damn communist and that puts
them on.
Is that what it's on?
Because men,
hilarious.
It's on a and e and they used to be like
fucking masterpiece theater and shit.
He used to have like an arts and
entertainment,
you know,
interesting.
Fascinating programming and stimulated
the mind map.
Don't sell cars now it's fucking,
you know,
people let found a storage box.
What's in the storage box?
Well,
but there's a lot of good stuff in
there.
I bet there's no more after the break.
I'm wondering how much you take for that
$500.
I can't give you five.
I gotta I gotta get at least four.
I don't know.
To commercial a narrative arc.
I'll tell you.
This is my last offer and I'll be in
serious cut to commercial.
Wow.
Wonder what his last offer is going to
be.
He got them down to three.
I wish I could say there hadn't been
guilty of this too.
Dude.
Just blessed.
Sorry to interrupt you though,
but last week I was.
I was in Mozambique and where I was
staying they had one of these satellites
with 700 channels and I was scrolling
through and who do I come upon?
Joe Rogan fear factor some.
There was some thing shooting fish
through the air and some woman in big
waiters had to catch the fish.
I wish I could remember.
It was another level.
Wasn't your favorite episode?
We did a $100.
40th
eight of them more actually because we
did seven or six.
Six,
I think.
Six more upon return.
So we did.
Yeah.
We did a full season,
like the biggest time.
It was like 34 episodes,
34 one hour shows.
Were you having fun or are you
contractually prohibited from discussing
it or not at all?
No,
I mean it was.
It wasn't like doing standup or it
wasn't like working for the UFC or
anything like that,
but the people were really nice that
worked on the show.
They became good friends and they were
fun folks.
We had fun,
you know,
like it was a real nice crew and when
when you have that,
it's like that,
that that's like the most important
thing about working on a show.
It's a family,
right?
You're with the same people all day,
but ultimately the product itself,
like you know what I mean?
It's mindless entertainment,
you know?
It's a competition of ridiculous
competition.
That's good to distract you if you look
up for some distraction,
but it shouldn't.
It's junk food,
junk food for the mind.
Not that it's anything,
nothing bad about it,
but nothing good about it either.
There's no no reason to think that it's
going to elevate anything in any way,
but it's better than arguing over how
much you going to pay for a container.
I mean,
I guess it is,
but there was real human drama and fear
factor that was undeniable.
People really shit their pants when they
were forced certain stunts and stunts
and think ridiculous thing they had to
eat.
It's a miracle fucked up for real and
that I was just talking to my good
friend David Horowitz,
who will be,
we're going to figure out a day to put
him on the podcast.
He was the executive producer of the
show,
one of the executive producers,
him and mack units and uh,
we were talking about on the phone the
other day.
We're like,
I told them,
I go,
I want to be honest with you,
man.
I'm glad they ended the last season I go
because I think it was like on its way
to being like it was so wrapped up with
a stunt is getting more and more risky.
Way More.
Yeah.
Well,
I don't want to say risky because it's,
I'd be ignorant to say that I'm not a
stunt man.
I'm not a stunt designer.
I don't know what's dangerous and what's
not.
I don't know what just looks dangerous
was actually pretty safe,
but all I know is that it became more.
They were starting to get more and more
spectacular.
We were,
they had these people attached with a
Bungee cord to a helicopter and the,
I mean there were like 200 helicopters,
like 200 yards away on this enormous
bungee cord.
And uh,
they had,
uh,
their partner had an undo locks and when
they undid the locks,
they have to find the right key,
like this giant ring of keys.
And if they did it within a certain
amount of time,
the person got launched off of this tree
like fucking 100,
200 yards into the air on a bungee cord
attached to the bottom of the
helicopter.
It was fucking crazy.
And I remember they were describing the
hell.
They're like,
well,
you know,
we have to be careful with this because
you've got to make sure that the people
don't pull the helicopter at a weird
angle.
That makes the helicopter
control.
Imagine as you're following the
helicopter just slices you in a
hamburger.
We did a lot of
just where people hung from helicopters,
but that's really not that big of a
deal.
They just hanging over water,
you know,
if they fall,
they just land on the water and they're
not growing nearly as fast as it looks
like boosh though.
That's the job,
but you're going to live.
It just.
It sucks.
It feels weird,
but you're going to live and you learn a
lot about human beings from shit like
that though.
It's fascinating because between that
and what do an MMA commentary a real.
I know a lot about seeing people when
they're.
When they're breaking like the at the
point where they can't,
they can't tolerate anymore and they
give up.
There's a give up point that some people
have it,
some people don't even have it.
Some people will never give up.
They just have this,
that,
that whatever.
That give up thing is a part of them is
broken.
They don't,
they don't even consider it.
They'll just march forward their face
hanging off.
Is this Guy Diego Sanchez or fights like
that?
This guy might not be the most skilled
fighter.
He's very skillful,
might not be the most skilled,
but he's one of the most crazy in that
he's not going to quit
that.
This is dangerous man.
Did you see that video?
If those two guys at the spa who broiled
themselves,
did you see that they broil themselves?
It's like a competition,
like who can get in?
It's like a spa,
right?
You could say in stay in the spa the
longest in this,
in this sauna and it's these two guys
and they like,
you know,
it's a,
it's an elimination process.
These are really disturbing pictures if
you show them,
but it's like basically a one of the
guys died,
like he roiled himself this thing
because
he wouldn't get out.
He wouldn't listen to his body broiled.
He just cooked himself like a fucking
lobster in there and I think one of the
guys survived,
but there's just a picture of him you
can find if you google search,
like guys fried and sauna and I don't
know what it is,
but it's like he's just laying there and
his whole body's rigid.
He's like,
you know,
like,
like you put a fucking,
like a lighter on a ant,
which God forgive me.
I did want when I was a kid,
I know,
but it's just like that.
Like he just curled up and he's bright,
blistered,
read really horrible because he wouldn't
give up and what a dumb ass waited a you
die at a spa.
He died with his slippers on massage to
slippers on rubber slippers.
They gave you a fatal relaxation.
The Guy,
he's a fucking hero in my book.
Got Bald guys.
Got He didn't give up.
Is An interesting thing though.
You see like people who rise to the
occasion and people who doubt
themselves,
you see them like fumble and stumble
because the pressure and some people
find a way to like get through it.
That's one of the more fascinating
things about watching anything that's
competition is that we wonder how we
would do in that scenario and we're
almost always fall short,
so we're always in awe of the guy who
manages to get by all those people that
are trying to drag them to the ground
and carry that ball across the line,
but with the list of things that people
are afraid of consistently.
Number one,
after death,
of course it's public speaking.
Right,
and here you guys are to Standup
Comedians,
right?
I give public presentation.
I mean I think that's.
That's a big one.
I mean I don't know how it compares
adrenaline wise to hanging from a
helicopter and a Bungee cord or sauna,
competition,
sauna off show that.
Pick.
Look,
I can't find the gross one.
It's just to show.
Just told it from the Internet.
That's not the guy.
It's like a guy's like maybe somebody
tweet or maybe it's not the real
picture.
Maybe you got a picture of a Jpeg of
this guy getting broil.
Man.
It's really.
I know it's true.
Duncan,
have you almost died in a song once?
Yeah,
but I had been drinking a lot and then
decided to have sex with my girlfriend.
We passed out in the sun and we were
alone and luckily I woke up somehow.
You guys are fucking lightweights,
but sad to say that it was exactly what
I was going to say.
Chris Ryan fucks like a man and she was
a folly ballplayer.
I'm lucky I didn't break my Dick.
That was really powerful.
Strong athletic,
Puerto Rican volleyball.
Play Jesus.
Good God,
man.
Now he's still alive.
A sauna is that?
We'll go.
Yeah,
that's real man.
Look at his skin falling off.
That's it.
And he's all rigid.
He's daddy Friday,
Bro.
He broiled himself.
He themselves dying right there.
I think he's probably dead already
there,
but he's.
Jamie.
What's the scroll down right there.
Hold on.
It's being removed from the sauna.
Oh my goodness.
That guy got fucking cooked.
He got cooked to literally cook
themselves for what?
A trophy.
Probably one.
At least $5.
It's ridiculous.
It's so silly.
Humans get lured into awful things.
I got to appear.
Yeah,
that is a weird thing,
man.
Darwin award.
That's a Darwin award winner right
there.
It is,
but you know,
we,
we also,
if,
if he won and it was like a million
dollars or something like that,
and he was okay,
we would applaud him for his ability to
withstand extreme agony.
We somehow or another admire people that
are willing to survive extreme agony and
the force of endurance races and things
for something meaningful though,
not for a million dollars,
you know?
I mean,
what's weirder this are dying in a super
marathon while those 100 marathons,
100 mile marathons and your fucking out
both Kinda dumb.
Really?
Yeah.
I mean nothing against athletes,
but yeah,
I just,
I,
I find all that kind of hardcore
competition,
meaningless.
I just read a very interesting book
called man's search for meaning by
Viktor Frankl who was in the
concentration camp in world war two.
He was a psychiatrist and he said,
he said the,
the how of anything is resolved.
If you find the why and what he meant
was you can survive anything if it's
meaningful.
If it's not meaningful anything,
we'll take you down.
Wow.
It's very interesting book.
Beautiful Book.
Anyway,
I don't know why the hell I'm talking
about that.
Oh,
insurance,
right?
Because he endured Auschwitz,
you know,
so I find that,
that's obviously incredibly admirable,
but somebody is like,
you put yourself in that position.
I was talking to a friend in Africa and
he was joking.
He was like,
you know,
only white people die,
bungee jumping and you know,
motorcycles jumping and all this.
So that's a white dude thing.
If I told my mother I died bungee
jumping,
or if someone told me my mother had
died,
bungee jumping,
she'd be like,
that idiot was bungee jumping you.
He didn't die from malaria or starvation
or you know,
like what have you,
white.
Well that's a hack standup comedian.
Premise that's for black comics will
talk about like camping,
that's a big thing,
but they're terrified of bears and black
people don't go camping.
It's like the whole thing that like
white people go bungee jumping.
White people jump out of a helicopter
and ski down the side of a mountain.
So maybe he stole this from Dane Cook.
No,
I don't think it's probably an obvious
premise because it's true like a lot of
things.
There's a lot of parallel thinking when
it comes to the realization.
If you live in an incredibly dangerous
environment like Africa and you're
looking at white people that are,
you're not looking for danger jumping,
what are you doing?
Stupid.
I mean it seems to be.
It writes itself.
It's not like you can't like see how a
lot of people would come to the same
conclusion.
It's true.
People are fucking hang gliding and
shit.
Getting those fucking wing suits and
flying to downtown.
I can't even watch that shit.
Yeah.
Dude,
you Saturday,
did you see that video of the Gay Dance
Troupe and Alabama?
Yes,
I tweeted it so awesome that they hired
by accident.
Tell the story.
Well
like they hired like some,
they,
they hired like a gay,
a female impersonator dance troupe to
accidentally for this parade and they
like,
they like,
what was the name of the dance troupe?
I can't remember the name.
I don't remember what it was.
Something ridiculous.
But what's so funny is you have.
So here's what you have,
you have these like gay dancers and
they're interviewing them and like
combining that with interviews with an
angry mothers like my child never should
have had to see something like that.
She's clearly the Satanist,
right?
She's like a pawn of the dark Lord.
She's an angry,
angry person.
These guys,
they're just saying like,
they're saying like,
man,
if this came to my town,
I would be fucking thrown money on them.
It's just hilarious.
It's fabulous.
It's great,
man.
They're,
they're good to come on.
That's funny.
In,
in the,
in the interview that they did with him,
they threw out like Alan Watts level
wisdom.
One of them says at the end of the day
we just came to dance.
It's really beautiful and sweet.
Meanwhile,
this white angry white ladies like at my
child will never be the same.
My child dancing cool Santa Claus outfit
on.
Yeah,
yeah,
yeah.
It's really good.
It's really weird.
Like she'd be laughing with her.
I'll tell you why these people don't get
any weed.
That's what it is,
right?
Weed is just not.
Not really getting down there.
If we were high and we were at the side
of the road and that we are here and we
would,
we might join them.
Fuck if I pull your shirt up and join
it,
that would be distracting them from
their work that they've obviously put
me.
Being a heckler thinks he's funnier than
the comedian,
so.
Yeah,
because they've.
Obviously.
That was the other thing about it.
Like that shit was choreographed.
It's true.
It's not their fault.
The fucking people hired him,
didn't really know what they are
getting.
It's like being a comic and you get
booked for a club and they go,
well,
we expect you to work clean.
Well,
I expect you to know what the fuck I do
before you hire me.
Yeah,
I'm here,
dude.
You either want me to do comedy or not,
but you don't get to tell me what to do.
It's like when Ted,
you know,
the thing with Ted had Sarah Silverman
and then she came out and did what Sarah
Silverman always does and then the next
day the head of Ted tweeted that it was
the most God awful performance he'd ever
seen and he was embarrassed to have
invited her and shit.
Like,
how,
how were you surprised that Sarah
Silverman says shit that's offensive.
Well,
what was her premise?
What was she going on to,
uh,
to talk about?
Do you know?
She just did her stand
up routine.
She did the thing talking about,
uh,
you know,
adopting a baby with terminal illness,
that you haven't heard that.
Oh,
that's great.
It's,
it's,
you know,
the whole thing is like,
I love kids and you know,
she does it with her cute Sarah
Silverman thing,
but I love babies,
but they get older and then they get,
it's problematic.
And so there's so many kids who need
parents.
I'm going to adopt children with
terminal illnesses,
so they die when they're seven or eight
and then I can get another one.
Yeah,
he is great.
Fucked up.
But it's obviously comedy,
like this idea that,
and this is one of the grossest things
that's going on these days.
I've actually started talking about this
on stage.
There's a real problem with people
pretending that jokes are statements and
if this is your actual opinions,
like there's an art to sank fucked up
shit.
You don't really mean.
If I know that you don't really mean it,
it's fun.
You and I do it all sense of comedy.
Duncan Duncan will call me up and say
the most ridiculous shit and I'll say,
well that sounds like a good idea.
Long.
How long have you been working with
them?
You know,
Joe,
I've seen the error of my ways.
You're like,
hang in there for like five minutes.
But when he got taken by the NSA to the
camp,
the camp,
that was fantastic on my podcast,
I said that I've been taken to the camry
education education camp and then like
me and Brendan Walsh just sing songs
about how great the beaches just turned
into this like vapid big.
But man,
I think that like that.
It's what people forget is that it's the
intention,
the intention.
I think people feel like there's cheap
laughs that people get away with at the
expense of other people's feelings and
that's why they don't like certain kinds
of of of jokes.
I agreed there's,
there's a,
there's a balance and there's.
There's off-color subjects that are
absolutely done hilarious and then
there's off color subjects that are done
crudely and it's almost insulting how
bad the material is and you're obviously
just doing it just for shock value and
we know the difference between the two.
It's a difference between someone you
want to listen to where they're
carefully considering what they're
saying and then someone who's just not
really either capable of or not willing
to look deep enough to get true insight.
So when they both have to be accepted
though,
because you can't have one without the
other.
It's a judgement for them.
You need shit comedy to compare comedy.
You need bad experiences.
I think the hack for life is far as bad
experiences like the,
the sadness and the trouble,
and then the happiness is just exercise.
Just fucking workout in a brutally hard
way and avoid all that depression.
Just get all that shit out of your way.
Like if you get through a brutal
kickboxing workout or a Jujitsu workout,
regular normal nonsense.
Like I'm fucking leaving.
That's it.
I've got my shit.
Okay.
All right.
You're too tired to give it.
Yeah,
so it's just been choking me all night
leaving.
Okay.
That is a shocking thing about exercise
sometimes that I'm depressed and I
finally like drag myself out of the
House and go to the gym and just run and
sweat and then I'm in my car and I feel
great.
And it's like,
really?
That's all I am.
Is that it?
I just have to exercise.
There's no chance.
Well,
you're a fucking bag of chemicals.
You.
You want the mystical payoff?
I want it.
I want it to.
It's like some part of when you realize
just how very simple it is,
some part of you will reject that
because you want it to be complex.
You want to be,
you want it to be something like,
I don't want it to be complex,
just wanting to hurt less.
Well,
yeah,
it's always doing that to you anyway.
I mean there's a.
there's a transformative process
throughout every experience that you
have throughout your life.
Everything that you do,
you sort of get a balance on,
well now I know how to handle this
better this time.
The reality of the situation is we have
a certain amount of requirements that
our body needs.
It needs to move around.
It has to but doesn't it atrophies
because fairly useless,
like you have to keep it leaving and
good food to really appreciate the
movement of it.
You have to push it really hard.
He pushed it really hard.
It's like a drag racer,
like a race car that you could develop
into a race car.
You develop it just by pushing it and
pushing it and pushing it and it becomes
a race car or if you let it sit alone,
it becomes a really junky old shit box
that can't start anymore.
I mean literally it's almost that
simple.
I wonder if you really have to push it
though,
because I'm thinking of hunter gatherer
of people,
right?
Who are sort of the model for what the
body needs.
They don't really push it,
but they move constantly moving
constantly.
It's hard.
Have you ever gone hiking with pack and
go fucking workout?
Real workout.
Like you start to like walking up hills
all day,
man.
You got fucking exhausted.
Yes.
Nepal,
there's a guy we were talking about,
this guy that he.
There's a show called solo hunters and
these guys,
they take like these little,
um,
you know,
there's little gopros and attach them to
their rifle or bow and Arrow and they
have a camera with them.
They'd go out into the woods and hunt
bear and Moose and like crazy shit.
Well,
one of the guys,
this guy,
Remy Warren,
who's a world famous hunter,
he's got a vo two Max of a high level
endurance athlete and all he does his
height.
He just,
he hunts 300 days a year constantly
walking around at high altitude,
constantly walking around and hills and
high altitude carrying backpacks.
It's fucking hard work.
It's really hard work,
so that's what if you were going to
hunt,
like that's Chetty do you had to fucking
walk a lot and he was like,
hunting is not just like,
oh,
let's go to the animal place and go
shoot one of those fucking things and
drag it out of there.
I mean you got to find them.
You got to track and we got to sneak up
on them.
Especially in the old days.
You had dog shit equipment.
He had like bows and arrows that you
made yourself,
oh,
beers,
terrible.
And you got to get close enough to an
animal to use that thing.
And there's a common misconception that
like there were more deer back then and
actually there weren't.
There's more deer today in North America
than they've ever been.
Way more than like when Columbus first
got here because of management,
because all of the different habitats
because a farm lands,
they thrive and farmland.
So
because of the absence of predators,
which humans killed,
it was just a stronger park in Africa a
week ago.
Intense place.
Really interesting place and I was
thinking about that very issue of like
how because you drove Kruger park is
this big area.
It's,
you know,
I don't know how big it is,
but it's,
it's like a county size or bigger
and they're just dirt roads and you just
sort of drive around and the deal is you
can never get out of your car because
there are leopards and lions and all
sorts of crocs and shit everywhere.
But you see a lot of stuff.
I mean there we saw during the day we
probably sold five or six lions just
along the side of one of these roads,
dirt roads.
So if there are five or six lines just
along the road,
how many lions are there in that place?
You know,
it's like there's a lion every hundred
meters along the road.
Well,
how many fucking lines going a place
like that support of all my friends,
you're the most likely to get eaten by
an animal and just realized that.
Well,
did you know that in in those areas of
the South Africa especially like a lot
of those places where wild animals
exist,
they're fenced in.
Yeah,
that is a lot of what they call high
fence hunting operations in South Africa
because it's a dirty secret about Africa
and about a lot of North America,
but even more dirty about Africa because
Africa,
a lot of his trophy hunting,
the amount of money that people pay to
go hunting over there is real.
That's responsible for a great deal of
the money that's used for conservation
efforts.
Like there's also for importing animals
like they've.
There's more a lot of African animals in
Texas than there are in Africa because
in Texas they bring them to these wild
wild hunting ranches like thousands and
thousands of acres and they just have
these deer just live there.
They just live in Texas now and they
just live off the land and then they,
you know,
they take guided trips to go and hunt
these things,
but they have African wild animals that
are running around like Sitka deer and
shit running around,
access deer running around in Texas.
It's weird with these people who paid
for like hunting licenses,
they go over and I mean it's Kinda crazy
like there was a piece on how cowardly
it is to hunt alliance like someone
showed it on this website because
they're just sitting there like all you
do is you run up to the difference
between a normal day in a day where the
car shoots them is that a metal stick
comes out and then all of a sudden their
life ends.
So they're just sitting there.
They have no idea.
You're a threat.
They have no idea that this is a game
that we're playing.
We're going to shoot the line.
They're just just sitting there chilling
and then someone comes along.
We'll isolate lion,
like it's kind of fucked,
but people want to be able to say that
they killed a line as if there were
danger
whatsoever.
Yeah,
yeah.
A lot of them are doing.
They're doing it from trucks or junior
from the roof of trucks is a great
hemingway short story about a guide who
takes a man in his wife out to hunt
lions and the guy is about to shoot the
line and the line charges and the dude
freaks and the guide has to kill the
lion when he's about to kill the guy.
And uh,
and then that night the guides leaves
with the guy's wife Holla course.
Hemingway.
So fucking manly.
Did you ever see that?
A Woody Allen movie where,
um,
I think it's called midnight in Paris.
Owen Wilson movie.
He goes back in time and he meets
hemingway.
Yeah.
That was pretty fascinating.
I love that premise.
All the different writers and painters
and stuff that were there.
Yeah,
just the idea of meaning.
Hemingway,
man.
It's just getting drunk with them.
Some people live like really live man.
Some people were like,
when I hear your stories about African,
like you've been everywhere,
listen to you.
Woe is me.
You just got back from a fucking treat
with Rom Dawson.
No,
I don't feel so silly.
I don't feel.
I don't feel woe is me,
I'm just saying like when I was there
when I was at that retreat,
and by the way that's not like in Africa
there's no lions there,
cougars,
but like they're more with crystals.
But when,
when I was um,
you know,
when I was there,
you would run into people who all they
do is just travel.
They figured out how to do it.
They just travel around the world and
you're Kinda like that.
Are you still make a traveler?
You see you were just in Africa?
Yeah,
but I was there because my,
my wife's daughter was getting married.
Right.
I mean I didn't go to Africa.
I used to for years,
for 15,
20 years.
I,
the thing that most,
most meaningful for me was movement and
travel and seeing new cultures and all
that.
So like you're talking about backpacks,
man,
I wear a backpack for 15 years.
Like,
well you're the real deal,
dude.
You're,
you're a guy who really made that
choice.
You're a guy like,
you know what?
Nope,
I'm going to have a bunch of really cool
experiences in a bunch of adventures.
But just like anything else,
you SORTA,
you get to a been there,
done that point,
and it started to be like,
man,
you know what,
another stamp in my passport really
doesn't fucking matter anymore.
You have a real gift for podcasting.
I'm glad you're willing to take if you
have a gift for the narrative that may
not,
may not come through in just a printed
word as much because he can't hear you
say it right now.
There's this.
It's not just the thoughts that you say,
it's how you say it and you're,
you were very good at it,
you know,
so the idea that you didn't do it before
and now that you have done it,
like the idea that you're going to just
travel around the world and not give us
fresh podcasts,
people's like this bullshit,
bro.
That's true,
man.
I'm really glad you're doing.
The guy who got me into it is Duncan.
I mean Danielle,
Ellie,
I'm really glad he's doing it as well.
It's a cool thing and I'm glad you're
doing this.
Well,
I mean it's a,
it's podcasting is one of the and most,
uh,
fascinating entrance into the world of
medium that's ever existed.
It's one of the,
one of the weirdest and one of the ones
where you can,
I think probably affect the,
the,
like the curve of society.
I think the curve of society is going to
get affected more by fascinating
podcasts then buy virtually anything
that they've ever had as far as like
the,
like exposed electronic media,
whether it's television,
whether it's radio.
I think all those things had a big
impact,
but I think podcasting and viewer
created or you know,
a regular user created content,
whatever it may be,
people with Webcams,
people writing blogs like this,
this new stream of stuff that's coming
down the pipe now.
It's so different.
There were,
there were no podcasts like yours.
It did not exist when I was in high
school.
If it did exist when I was in high
school,
me and my friends would a huddled around
candles.
Okay.
We would have sat around listening and
we would have talked about,
do you think Dunkin's right?
Yeah.
My Dad's a fucking asshole,
he just wants me to suffer like and
he'll fucking regret it on his dying
death bed,
but will I let him regretted?
Fuck No,
I'm taking my guitar and I'm fucking
hitchhiked into Canada and that's.
And I think you know that that exists
now in mass.
I'm not
doing it.
You're doing it.
There's so many of our friends have
podcast bill burn and Brian Cowen and
Ari Shaffir and Joey Diaz.
It's like a fucking epidemic.
And you want to talk about an epidemic
of entertainment.
It's podcasting is an epidemic.
Yeah,
it's definitely,
it's,
I,
I wonder what it's going to evolve into
because it's still in the early
embryonic phases of the thing.
I wonder what it's going to be in 15
years,
what it will be or how it will be
accepted or,
or what it will be.
I'm sure it's going to vary.
Just like everything else varies.
It's like books,
like,
you know,
there's books that are dog shit.
You're not going to get a goddamn thing
out of him and his books that you read,
like the war of art.
It just read a couple of passages and
you're like,
God,
yes,
it's fucking guys nailing it,
right?
Like,
Holy Shit.
Like this is a real game changer.
This is a,
uh,
this guy has given me the tools to
reapproach my,
my way of looking at the very thing I do
for a living.
Like,
wow,
this is kind of nuts.
You know?
So there's,
there's,
there's a lot of variation when it comes
to podcasting,
but it's the possibility that someone
could just express something and it can
get there immediately.
Think of it all the time and effort.
You had to put two,
creating a book like sex at dawn,
and think about if you just decided to
break that discussion up into x amount
of podcasts and just freely relay your
experiences on the subject,
the information where you got it from.
Passionately talk about these cultures
where these people have these unique
experiences with each other.
Passionately.
Talk about the roots of common
misconceptions about things like
promiscuity and a lot this,
it's all missing in a flat word.
You know,
you could get that,
you gather the pros and you know,
you can kind of paint the.
But to hear a person say it,
you know,
to hear you talk about your work is
almost more rewarding.
Yeah.
And it's.
And it's very rewarding on,
on my side is a writer because the thing
is like,
I'm not one of these people who always
wanted to be a writer.
I always had people telling me I should
be a writer because when I wrote
something it worked,
you know,
but I never liked.
Right.
I still don't like writing and people
get really disappointed to hear that.
Like,
Oh,
you know,
what's your process and my process.
I just avoided it as long as possible
and then do it,
you know,
that's my process.
I hate it.
I really like public speaking and I like
stuff like this because there's an
immediacy to it.
You know,
it's the difference between sitting in a
studio and making a record and doing
concerts.
It's,
it's energy.
If you're not terrified by public
speaking is none of us are.
You guys know better than me.
It it fills you with energy to be on
stage and see people responding to what
you're saying as opposed to draining it
out of you.
Right.
Also,
I think that I can clearly see that
benefited greatly from all these
conversations.
Like I know me personally,
it's expanded my thought.
It's an education 100 percent.
It gives people a reason to take time
out of their day and talk with you,
which is so cool.
It's also
made me very enthusiastic about
communicating with people and I think
the art of conversation,
you know,
I think we're so lost in the day to day
grind where people have to pretend to be
something they're not for the majority
of their day.
They have to be reserved.
You can't make jokes,
you can't talk about anything that's
really crazy or current commercial
because you have to work,
you know you're there to work.
You're not there to be yourself,
so there's all this suppression and then
when people get free of that,
now you know how much time do they
really have to truly open up and the
more people you are around that are
exposing you to different thoughts.
One of the things that I love about
talking to you as you and I often agree
on things,
but we also have wildly different
perspectives that we come at things from
and your.
You'll oftentimes come at something.
Well,
I'll go,
yeah,
I didn't fucking know I agree with you,
but you're coming at it from such a
weird place that I probably never would
have considered,
but because you're my friend,
I get to consider that and then I get
enriched by this possibility and then
you being my friend,
you will come up with another
possibility and we all feed off of each
other.
And then other people listened to that
and they say,
Hey,
I was listening to Duncan trussell talk
about this thing and Christopher Ryan
said that this.
And then and then boom,
and that branches out and then it
spreads from there.
The enhancement that you feel in having
these conversations is contagious.
It's contagious to other people that are
listening to it.
I met people in,
in Maputo,
Mozambique who listened to Dunkin's
podcast.
Seriously,
completely randomly,
right.
I'm sitting at a table in this wedding
and I said something about a podcast and
then someone at the table is like,
oh,
I listen to like,
who do you listen to it,
you know?
And he's like,
Oh,
this Guy Duncan trussell,
I think he's in La.
And it's like,
I heard of him.
Yeah.
It's fucking bad.
So I got an email from someone saying a
fedex driver in Utah who listens to my
podcast when he's driving and I'm sure
yours as well since we're all sort of in
the same.
And a woman in Finland who listens to it
when she's commuting to work in the
morning,
she got up and she wants to know she's
got to be hot and it's dark up there all
winter.
She wants a hug.
She wants,
she wants to make sure we don't get.
It's got to go to the bathroom again.
The if you just stop and think about the
amount of downloads and the amount of
episodes,
just throw it out there.
You know what this podcast is?
I think that,
what do we like?
Four 30,
400,
30,
433rd podcast.
Each one of them is,
the majority of them are at least two
hours long.
Most of them are three.
The majority of my three hours,
there's only a few that are like an hour
or more.
Just slightly more so that's a lot of
time.
That's a lot of fucking information
that.
Yeah.
Can I just say what we're talking about
this.
It sounds like an ass kiss thing here,
but you have really kind listeners.
Every time I'm on your podcast,
I get so many tweets and emails from
people and nobody's being a dick.
I'm sure there are addicts out there,
but for some reason they don't bother
writing.
Thank you.
Dicks.
It's beautiful.
Yeah,
I mean people are just so enthusiastic
and supportive and cool.
It's a really interesting self selected
community,
I guess because people who are dicks
probably wouldn't be attracted to this
podcast.
Well,
I think people resonate with like the
imitator atmosphere to a great extent
and if you grow up in a terrible place
or a place that has weird tribal
cultures,
I mean we've seen it time and time
again,
go back to Africa and like the tradition
of putting plates in your lips to
signify how many cows you get.
It's not a weird fucking things that
people do and you can get in a bad group
and you can get into bad pattern and you
can get into a bad groove that a lot of
other people are also in and it's really
easy to do and you see that in.
There's radio stations that have
followings where it's known that if you
go on stage with the opiate,
that ego.
I love Opie and Anthony,
but it was
no in amongst a lot of comedians.
If you get up there,
we're going to fucking torture you.
Like bill burr has a famous video of.
This is my favorite radio show ever open
anthony show,
so I'm not criticizing them.
But there are a bunch of men talk and
shit and they're what they call the
pests.
So the listeners,
they're fucking savages sap badges and
they booed dom irrera and after they
blew down the road,
Bill Burr is a huge [inaudible] fan,
always has been.
So Bill went on after him and just tore
the whole city a new asshole just kept
talking shit about Philadelphia,
but they created that somehow or another
with their intentions with their
broadcast,
what they put out in their broadcast.
And I did not plan on this in any way,
shape or form.
This is just something that's happened,
all of it.
The amount of positivity that's come out
of it,
the attitude of the people that this
idea of embracing health and,
and,
and good thinking and being kind to
people being of paramount importance.
One of the most important things in your
life,
not get your shit together,
not you be the fucking man,
not you.
Be Successful.
No number one most important thing is to
be nice.
It's like the most important thing.
Be kind until you can't be kind.
So you got to tell people to shut the
fuck up.
Come on,
you're killing me.
You know,
it's be kind until you hit that point 90
yourself to fuck.
Yeah,
and also be willing to do that same shit
to yourself.
You're willing to be like super
objective to super self analytical and
be just.
Just try to get through this and realize
that if five people can do it,
5 million can do it.
It's that simple.
Like I always say like this room,
here's a perfect example.
This is.
I beaten it to death,
but it's a good one.
If we were the only people on the
planet,
if it was just us and we existed on this
weird island and everywhere else,
like,
look guys,
we got a lot of food here.
We're fine.
I mean this is a vibrant ecosystem.
Has No predators.
We can live here.
We're going to be okay.
Oh,
you were fucking Duncan.
You know,
we found this weird sex shit.
Get that out of the way.
He's got the beard is like,
where are the girls?
We have to find girls.
I know as soon as he said like us guys
on an island,
I'm thinking
us friends,
if we were in any place where we were
forced to be together,
we would ultimately figure out a way to
work it out.
It would suck if there weren't girls.
You're right,
but ultimately there would be no wars.
What my point is,
there will be,
there wouldn't be a war,
you know,
you and I have net.
We've even the minor disagreements,
so we have ever had ever in our 10 plus
year friendship,
they've been cured off with a couple
sentences back and forth instantly and
always super cool and always on like,
you know,
I would never say anything on purpose to
hurt your feelings.
That's not what a friend does ever.
Well,
if we lived on an island together,
it'd be the same thing.
I wouldn't.
All of a sudden it'd be like,
you know what the Fuck Dunkin,
you gotTa Stop Smoking Weed or I'm going
to put you in my canoe cage,
made a cage in his fucking canoe and I'm
going to wrap you up in there and you're
not following my fucking rules out the
cage.
You can.
Oh,
I would say,
you know,
I need all the fucking mangoes.
Bitch.
I got a gun.
You guys don't have any guns left.
I got.
I need the fucking mangoes.
I want the mangoes.
I'm tired of eating my mangoes and you
know what you're talking about is,
has happened a large scale.
Six or seven,
the flies.
It's a lord of the flies situation that
that's how it was framed in the article
because the Lord of the flies,
of course,
for people who don't know what is this
book about?
Kids who get stranded on an island
somewhere and it turns into this really
nasty hobbs,
Ian,
you know,
dominating society.
Some kids,
if they break the kids glasses and it's
all and shaky
piggy,
right?
But,
but what?
Fuck him,
I was that deliberate.
Those deliverance to burt reynolds.
Fuck them in deliverance.
Fuck that kid.
A blind kid.
Oh,
even worse,
but no,
these kids actually did get stranded on
an island somewhere.
I don't remember the the basis of the
story,
but it was a historical event and they
cooperated,
took care of each other and survived
months,
you know,
and there wasn't any of that nastiness,
this whole hobbsy and idea.
We were talking earlier about the
dominant paradigm in the bullshit that,
you know,
network tv was putting out for so long
that it's now getting subverted by the
Internet and buy all these different
channels of information.
For me,
one of the most pernicious ones is this
idea of human nature being nasty in its
essence.
The Hobbs Ian view of.
I take it you're not a fan of the
walking dead.
No,
I just find it boring.
I watched the first season or something
and then it was like,
okay,
right.
The heads of blow up.
The classic scenario of people wind up
being their worst enemies around the
Zombie seem pretty easy to deal with
after awhile because people that become
the real issue,
including,
you know,
the men who want to choose the Alpha is
always.
We'll see the,
the,
the notion that we even have an Alpha
is,
is more complicated than it seems.
You know,
we're not.
Humans never organized themselves into a
wolf packs.
That's not the way we live.
Know never did live that way.
Fatty while he never seen me and my
boys.
When we go out,
Chris Ryan,
Wolf Pack,
we all went to move in together.
We slap our chest three times all in
synchronous.
Oh God.
Well,
we'll pack jackets as well.
Past my scattered gene.
Letters over leather.
They,
that's what they call us.
They call it the woolpack.
And could you basically deal basically
like lone wolves gathered together,
gathered together a group of lone
wolves,
gang up.
Well,
the,
you know what?
We have to ultimately realized that
there's we 100 percent need each other.
It's one of the most important things.
We also 100 per cent need the people.
If you want to truly be happy,
you need the people around you to like
you and you need to have them.
They have to have a reason to like you,
like you have to be giving out as much
as you're taking away or more.
And if that doesn't see this,
that what you just said is that the
basis of what I think is one of the
greatest misunderstandings in human
evolutionary theory,
which is,
you know,
they use game theory to try to work out
how our ancestors lived in one of the
assumptions is the freeloader
assumption,
which is that you can't possibly,
our ancestors couldn't possibly have
lived in a sharing kind of environment
economically because some people would
just take and take and take and not give
anything back.
Right?
And so that's a base assumption.
So then from that they justify
capitalism,
doggy dog
economics,
right?
And they say,
well,
it must have been that way,
but the fact is shame is a hugely
motivating force and as you just said,
we are designed by nature to really care
whether the people around us love us or
not.
And if they don't,
it freaks us out.
So people work always to give back to
the group,
right?
Because if you're not giving back to the
group,
if you worst case scenario,
you get banished by the group,
you're dead,
right?
This is why they stayed at the party.
Your brain,
that experiences rejection is in a
different part of the brain hurts worse
than anything.
Yeah,
it does too.
And that's why kids are so cruel with
each other.
When they reject each other,
when they're at play,
we're not playing with you anymore.
Oh,
they're exercising that little muscle.
Figuring out like,
oh look,
I can get someone to dance.
You know,
man Shit.
To them,
this is like the thing at this retreat
that they talked about that I really
love,
man is,
is.
So you're saying be kind to other
people.
Well,
the question is how can you be
authentically kind to the people around
you?
And the simple simple answer is you have
to love yourself first.
You can't reject yourself.
You can't be the rejecting force because
a lot of times your personality is a
personality constructed by people who
rejected you from the moment you started
talking your parents.
It's not even you,
so you're rejecting yourself.
The first thing is start loving
yourself.
Embrace yourself right now.
That's going to make a big change and
that cause like if you want to really
change somebody's,
love them,
love a person will get around unless
they're super annoying.
Just avoid them.
Love everybody.
You can't fix it.
I'm just saying,
no,
but here's you know,
you're right.
Certain people are of course,
but in general,
if you want to watch somebody change,
get around them and just like them,
just beam love at them and watch how
they act.
Because here's one thing that is certain
being mean to people does not make
people better because if it did,
we would live on a planet,
other cool motherfuckers.
This planet would be filled with the
sweetest people ever because we're also
cruel to each other.
It doesn't work.
That's very simplistic and here's why,
why
it is because it's not that everybody's
also mean to each other.
It's just that when we are mean to each
other,
it hurts so bad.
If you stop and think about your
interactions with people on a daily
basis.
There's very few main ones.
I went to the mall today and I wandered
through a couple of stores and I met a
bunch of people that said,
hi.
I met a bunch of people that were at the
fucking coffee beans stand.
They said,
hi.
I met a guy in the parking lot.
He said,
hi.
There was very little negative
interaction.
You know what I'm saying?
Like,
but when?
When it happens,
it's terrible.
It's just the real problem is when we
look at life today,
and it is a huge issue with our view of
the world is based on seven fucking
billion people and that's madness.
You can have the information,
the fears,
the tragedies,
the events of 7 billion people inside
your fucking head.
You can't that.
It's too God damn big.
Why don't you just think about the
infinite amount of living beings in the
universe itself?
Why not consider all the fucking mold
spores that are probably going to die
when someone sprayed lysol on them?
Let's go fucking hogwild and worry about
everything.
You can't.
If you want to get through your 24 hour
time period,
you know only of which you're awake.
16.
You got to fucking prioritize.
And if you don't fucking prioritize,
you're not going to have time to enjoy
this experience.
You're not gonna have time to take it
in.
You'll be caught up in the wave of,
of momentum,
of other people's ideas and you'll never
be able to catch yourself.
But rejecting someone takes energy.
And if I understand what you're saying,
called Verizon and change the number
that takes energy to,
I don't know how long have you been on
hold with verizon,
but uh,
you know,
what you were describing is,
it's a psychotherapeutic thing where
you're,
no matter who's sitting across the table
from you,
you have to accept them.
If you're not accepting them,
you're never going to be able to help
them.
It doesn't mean you have to like them,
doesn't mean you have to not be annoyed
by them,
but it means you'll respect them.
You respect like whatever it is that's
annoying about them is something that's
resonating in you.
The Carl Jung said like every person who
irritates you is an opportunity to learn
something about yourself because you
know that person is annoying to you in a
special sort of way.
Often Times you know,
and so there's something about you
that's interesting,
terrified of seeing that those words,
the implication of what you're saying is
if you embrace those qualities in
yourself that you can't even accept,
so you're casting them into the world,
then all of a sudden those people who
are so annoying to you stop being as
annoying because you're not seeing the
part of yourself you hate reflected on
the screen of them
possibly,
and also possibly they feel accepted so
they don't need to keep doing that
bullshit to you.
It's an experiment.
You can do an experiment and here's the
great experiment because probably for
your entire life,
when you get around Douche bags,
you either aggressively attack them,
passive aggressively,
attack them or try to get out of their
presence,
so do a little experiment.
The next time you get around a real
douche,
somebody who's like really fucking
annoying and the Douche temperature is
starting to turn up.
You don't have to stay there forever,
but look at them and look at their face
and you'll see lines in their face and
if you look at those lines,
you'll realize this douche bag has
suffered just like you have suffered
this douche bag,
his,
his suffered so much that they've
created a massive defense mechanism
called their personality,
which makes everyone think they're a
douche bag.
The world they wander through is a world
of faces looking at them with either
like a anxiety,
sadness,
a sense of claustrophobia and not
wanting to be in their presence anymore.
They're 40 or 50.
It's not working that the reaction the
world is giving them isn't only making
them more and more and more of a Douche
bag.
So this is compassion.
You recognize that this has suffered.
You don't have to stay in this way
forever.
I tried it the other night at a bar with
somebody passive,
hipster Buddhism,
ducking.
It lasted,
it lasted.
I was able to do it for like,
because this is like a guy I would never
ever,
ever be around.
Somebody brought him.
He's like this like just lucky weird
dude and he's like being just a pure
defense mechanism.
Dick.
I've just gotten back from this
meditation retreat.
So I'm like,
alright,
okay,
I don't care.
I'm going to see.
I'm going to find something in this
person that I can love that I can
connect to that I know that this person
is,
is gotten this way because you know,
who knows what.
So I open myself up much more than I
usually do in those situations.
I didn't go take a leak or I didn't just
go to some other part of the bar and
he's,
you know what he starts doing man,
he starts to like after this like whole,
like weird dickie,
like Alpha male thing.
All of a sudden he starts pulling out
his phone and he's showing me pictures
of his,
of his kids,
and it's like not an annoying thing.
He's like,
you.
He's faces now lighting up and he loves
his kids and he's just.
All of a sudden there's just this one
moment where the Douche has fallen away
and there's a sweet person who loves his
kids do it.
You should read Christmas movies.
Well,
I just,
it's,
it's a,
it's an observer.
If you know the observer effect and
quantum physics where they say the
observation effects the thing itself.
In that same way,
like if you're,
if you,
if you just start experimenting a little
bit with shining compassion out into the
world,
then you might get things bouncing back
that aren't these douche bags that
you're so used to encountering and you
don't have to trick yourself into
thinking like,
I'm going to be fucking Gandhi or Rom
dosser.
I've,
I'm always going to be in this state.
Just try to maintain the state for a
minute thing.
Go back to being a Dick,
you know,
maintain the state for two minutes and
if you can't do it then start punishing
the person or being weird or like
talking shit to him or talking shit
about him,
but just for try two minutes and see
what happens.
The effects are going to really amaze
you,
especially if your entire life you've
only been dealing with people in a
shitty way.
I've had to revise my whole.
Cut The vampire out of your life thing,
man.
I'm not sure if that's the right way to
do it.
I think it's love the vampire in your
heart.
I've got to revise.
Album is there's not enough time and you
know the real problem.
The number one real problem is how the
fuck did they get that way in the first
place and that's people are being raised
by shitheads,
so they're imprinting,
they're copying the behavior of
failures.
Like Duncan said it.
There's a deep rejection at the heart of
somebody like that.
I'm reminded of some,
some people,
some women I know who were sexually
abused and then immediately put on a lot
of weight right after,
right.
Protection,
risk protection,
and it's also remove me from that whole
dynamic with men.
I got hurt in that.
Remove me from it.
Make me unattractive to them.
Right.
So the guy who was being a dick,
he's being a dick in a way because he
can't stand to be rejected by you.
So he has to be never accepted yet.
Right.
And just like negate the whole whole
issue.
It's no fun man.
When you start,
when you compassion,
if you're,
if you get a kick out of like rejecting
people or if you get a kick out of like
creating a us and them paradigm,
it really is a uh,
it's a problem because suddenly when you
like realize like,
Shit,
man,
this guy's just like me.
You know,
he's,
if I had been in his situation,
I might even been more of a dick then he
is,
who knows,
you just don't know.
And it's cooked into our society.
This is the thing.
I mean,
I think you guys both probably agree
with this.
I think that we live in a deeply
pathological society and a healthy
person in the society is by definition
going to seem really strange,
you know,
because they're not,
they're not in sync with the society.
Have you heard of the continuum concept
now?
It's,
um,
it's a book written by a woman who found
herself pretty randomly living with more
or less stone-age tribe in Venezuela and
she observed the way they raise children
and she wrote this book and her and her
thesis.
This was in the late sixties,
early seventies.
The thesis is essentially when a baby's
born in this society,
that baby is in physical contact with
his mother or another adult basically
constantly until he or she doesn't want
to be anymore and is off running around
with their friends,
right?
There's.
Whereas in our society,
up until the fifties,
doctors were telling parents not to
touch their infants,
put the infant in the crib.
No matter how much it costs,
do not touch it.
By caressing your child,
you create pathology.
You create sickness and illness and
weakness.
This was until the 1950 right.
Lots of lots of kids died.
It was called hospital ism because the
problem is you had on the one side of
this sort of macho male asshole attitude
dominating medicine,
no woman doctors and the nurses opinions
didn't count for anything because the
men knew best and on the other hand you
had the germ theory is I'm talking early
20th century now where it was,
it was understood that contagion was a
big problem.
So they started putting newborn infants
in these incubators,
these isolation tanks and they weren't
allowing the mothers to even pick them
up and touch them because they had no
way of testing for germs.
They just knew,
you know,
germs were somewhere.
So all these kids are dying and the and
the nurses are saying,
well of course you got to pick them up
there crying.
Look,
you know the women are resonating and
the doctors are saying no,
you can't touch them.
No,
no,
no touching,
no touching.
And they were like 20,
25 percent death rate in the most modern
American hospitals that we're so weird.
It's really fucked up.
And someone will be so confident to
avoid the natural instincts.
You can't.
Well,
we override them all the time.
Right?
A masturbation,
it'll kill you.
It'll make you blind.
It'll make you crazy.
Well,
we will make.
If you do it wrong,
you're coughing your eyes,
your eyes,
and then into a tree
which is right up there on sauna.
Tying yourself to death as far as stupid
as.
Oh yeah.
That's texting while driving.
You go off a cliff.
Yeah.
There was a guy,
I think it was like Paris Hilton's
veterinary or a plastic surgeon or
something like that.
Like some famous plastic surgeon.
And he tweeted a second before he fell
off the side of a fucking cliff.
I really thing I just retweeted a thing
a few days ago.
Some some computer designer or somebody
who was working in the office tweeted A.
I've been on the job 30 hours feeling
great.
And then he died.
Yes.
Like at his desk,
wasn't it?
No.
You're talking about a woman who went,
no,
no.
It's another one I think you're thinking
of going on right now.
She went to Africa.
She was a PR woman.
Oh no,
that's.
Yeah.
She just landed in and it got picked up
because she didn't know that the AIDS
Joe.
She goes well off to South Africa.
Hope I don't get aids.
Just kidding.
I'm white.
Right?
That's exactly what it was.
Probably on Xanax.
It's probably had a glass of wine.
Didn't know what the fuck she was doing.
Woke up to a national controversy.
She had apologized.
Father said he was ashamed over some guy
went to the airport to meet her and took
some pictures and then interviewed her
father while they were waiting I guess,
and the father was like,
I can't believe she said that.
He's South African.
Speaking of weird stuff.
What about the Steve Martin thing?
Do you hear about this?
What he tweeted?
Somebody wrote like he was doing a back
and forth with some of his followers on
twitter and somebody wrote a l like
Lasagna,
l a s a n y a or something like that.
Is that how you spell a Sanya and he
wrote.
Well,
it depends if you're going to an African
American restaurant or an Italian
restaurant
and people got really offended by that.
He deleted the tweet and then when Cada
screenshot apologized and illegally.
Yeah.
What is wrong with that?
That's not nothing.
That's what I'm saying.
Like what's a
have about saying there's a black
American vernacular that sounds
different than you know,
like how is that insulting to anybody?
Well,
I had this conversation with someone
where I was talking about,
you know,
how you can listen to someone talk on
the phone and know if they're black.
And she was like,
no,
I don't know.
I go,
bullshit.
You do know I go,
it doesn't mean that there's anything
wrong with being black,
but you can tell when you're talking to
a lot of people on the phone,
you can tell if the guy's black.
Well,
you then let me.
I would argue that there are some people
who you can hear and know they're black.
Very common,
but that doesn't mean that you can
listen to anyone and another black.
There are a lot of black people who
would.
You wouldn't be able to tell.
Of course not.
I see a of white people that can say,
well,
yeah,
exactly,
but there is that quality that does
exists.
Of course there's nothing wrong with it.
Like the idea that that was she was,
she was looking at it like she wouldn't
touch it with a 10 foot pole because it
was politically incorrect and it was a
dangerous thing to discuss.
I'm like,
why?
Why is it dangerous to say that black
people oftentimes have a different way
of talking?
It doesn't.
It's not.
No one's saying bad or worse.
It's like saying that people that are
from the west coast,
they'll have a different way of talking.
Then people that live in Minnesota or
then people that live in New York,
of course they did dialect.
Of course they do.
It's not bad or.
Or it isn't like super intelligent.
People like fineman had a very
pronounced New York accent.
Right?
Didn't he?
And he was Jewish.
Yeah.
Pronounced Jewish New York accent and he
was one of the most brilliant physicists
ever.
Yeah,
I mean it doesn't mean anything,
but that's the thing in America now.
Anything around around sex,
you and I talked about this last time or
or race is,
is so explosive.
It here's a comedian,
Steve Martin,
come on.
He's been in the trenches forever.
Why is he retracting that?
Why is he apollo
going to die?
So that's my new song.
While he's a good guy,
I mean that's really what it is.
He's a nice guy.
He doesn't want anybody's feelings,
but yeah,
he was afraid of
offend them,
but I mean,
when people are offended over you
breathing,
fuck them.
You're right.
But he's not A.
I don't think he's a confrontational guy
at all.
He's an interesting cat.
You.
Steve Martin is a fascinating dude
because first of all he was unbelievably
hilarious and unbelievably innovative
when he first came out.
I mean he was a unique cat.
This whole thing was very unique.
It was.
His Act was very unique.
It was really funny and silly and slap
sticky,
but he's a unique guy in the fact that
he got huge,
really successful and then didn't like
the fact that people would laugh about
anything that he did and he didn't feel
like you had this real honest connection
with them anymore and like pulled away
from comedy,
couldn't,
couldn't do comedy in clumps anymore.
Like the Beatles stopped touring because
nobody could.
They're screaming so loud.
They couldn't hear the music.
I went.
I went to this talk with Steve Martin
and Steve Martin was there with an
author and [inaudible].
You were saying he's not
confrontational.
This was like six years ago.
He's there at Steve Martin's there with
this author.
It's clearly a big fan of this author
and somebody in the audience.
The audience is getting to ask questions
and some asshole says,
I have a question for the guy who isn't
Steve Martin and Steve Martin.
I can't remember exactly what he said to
this guy,
but it was a brutal evisceration of this
guy for being a disrespectful asshole.
Like you saw the color just rush out of
the guy's face.
I do,
it was the,
uh,
he's just being rude.
It's just by saying the guy who's not
like,
you're not dot Martin,
we don't care who you are.
Yeah.
It was just rude.
It was just like you didn't need to.
He did it to defend his friend.
Yeah.
And it was brutal.
And then you still see that guy still a
comic man because it was like,
you know,
like he hasn't stopped being a comic.
You just,
that thing,
that edge that's inside comics that'll
come out is definitely inside of him.
He's a brilliant guy.
You read his autobiography?
Yeah.
It's really good.
He's an interesting dude.
He breeds it on.
If you go to audible.com,
you can get it.
He actually reads it.
He's a,
he's a brilliant guy and a great movie
comedian.
I mean,
you back to the jerk.
That is a masterpiece.
It's still holds up.
I was born a poor black child.
He's not apologizing for that.
There is something that while he was a
young man,
then it's different.
I'm sure now he's just like,
he sounds like a great books of short
comedy essays that are hilarious.
Yeah.
He's a unique talent.
Steve.
Mine's a very unique town,
although I never bought him as a mob guy
that the one we played an Italian guy
and they've given the crazy hair.
Remember that?
I don't remember that.
Like a mob guy in the witness protection
program and moves into this straight or
comedy comedy comedy.
I mean,
when was the last time we did street
movie?
Just does it do a lot of great movies
now?
He did,
yeah,
he did.
Didn't he do like he did?
Is He.
He's done some serious.
Was he like in a woody allen movie
playing a straight character?
That's always.
When I stand up.
Comedian branches spread their wings.
They do a woody allen movie.
Well,
like Louis C,
k just did one.
Clay.
Andrew dice clay was in the same thing.
It was an article online about Andrew
Dice,
clay deserving.
Then Oscar for that role.
It was really good.
I just saw that on the plane.
I liked it,
but I didn't see a lot of drama there.
I mean,
he wasn't playing an autistic person or
I just thought it was very authentic.
I thought it was a really worked,
you know,
he's a good actor.
It's,
and it's surprising.
And Woody Allen,
you know,
recognize that.
Hey,
have you seen that preview for that
Werewolf movie coming out?
Of course.
I'm sure you have.
Yes.
Yeah.
What do you think?
It's one movie Dunkin.
It's an American Werewolf in London.
It's a God damn perfect movie of
preaching to the choir.
Everything since then sucks the fat that
the one where he takes acid and turns
into a werewolf,
which I resented that as an acid had at
the time.
The preview or William hurt?
No,
no.
I'm talking about American Werewolf in
London.
Oh no,
he got chomped.
You know,
you're thinking of alternate.
Oh,
that's right.
That premise up so bad monkey turned
into some sort of monkey from taking
acid.
Well,
he got into the sensory deprivation tank
that was based on living.
That's right.
That's the whole idea.
Yeah,
it's terrible.
Yeah.
I thought it was great at the time and
it was important to me because it got me
into isolation tanks,
but it's terrible if you try to watch it
now,
but the best part is the schizophrenia
on acid saying,
I feel like my heart is being touched by
Christ.
Remember,
that was a great line in that movie.
I can't.
I'm looking for new wedges.
Saw the river's edge.
Have you seen that?
What's that?
Quintin.
Crispin Glover University.
I saw it a long time ago.
It's a really strange movie.
That guy's too much for.
Very funny.
He's like Dunkin.
If he went completely off the ipad and
became a meth head and I need to start
doing math.
I fucking love.
Christmas.
Can be so crazy.
Like in his movies.
He's so good at what he does.
You know?
Who else is really good?
I can't remember the cat's name.
Why everyone's a cat today.
I can't remember the guy's name,
but he was,
uh,
one of the bad guys and the x files.
He's at one weird dude that you'd never
know his name.
But when he's in a,
on a movie like,
Oh,
this guy's
awesome.
He.
Yeah,
there,
there are several people like that.
Who is that old dude?
Creepy old dude.
I don't know what this werewolf movie
is,
man.
I can't find any,
uh,
things online.
Have you seen the trailer for
transcendence?
Yeah,
the trailer for transcendence looks
really interesting.
Have you seen the japs?
Well,
it's essentially the idea of the full
ray Kurzweil vision being realized with
one guy being Johnny Depp playing the
Kurzweil character gets killed by
somebody.
But as he's dying,
they download his consciousness into a
computer.
You got to play it.
That's pretty good.
She,
Jesus Christ requires us to one of the
most fundamental secrets of the
universe.
Imagine that machine with a full range
of human emotions intense will be
greater than the collective intelligence
of every person in the history of the
world.
Some scientists refer to this as the
singularity.
I call it transcendence series of
attacks conducted by radical anti-tech
group known as rift labs all over the
country.
We lost decades of research and
development.
It's radiation poisoning.
The bullet must've been laced with it.
The effect is the reversible will's body
is dying,
but his mind is a pattern of electrical
signals.
We can upload his consciousness.
We can save him.
Assuming that this works,
if we missed anything,
thought childhood memory.
How well do you know who you're dealing
with?
Well,
my God,
I can't.
I'm here.
Need to get me online.
I need more power,
maybe intelligent bait and be sent to
you.
Shove it down.
Your friends crossed a line out the
danger.
So how do we fight it?
Evolve?
Where's the machine?
Where are you going?
Wow.
That they could fuck that up.
That could be one of those movies where
like,
oh,
okay,
fuck head.
It already looks fucked up man.
Am I wrong?
Or does it seem like they told the whole
story in the.
That's what they do now.
We just did this.
The spoiler alert.
Just show me Jennifer Lawrence.
I just want to watch her.
She's so pretty.
She listens to your pocket.
Hope she does the American hustle movie.
She looks fantastic in that movie.
You're reaching out to Jennifer Lawrence
through Joe Rogan's podcast work.
I feel it happening now.
I think she should call me to set up the
date though.
Whatever it takes.
I'm sure she's a fan of your work.
Yeah.
Well that'll be an interesting pairing
with her mom.
You know this.
Do you know what I'm talking about her
the movie,
the new movie about the guy falls in
love with the computer program.
Yeah,
yeah,
yeah.
Yeah.
Which Duncan is living even as we speak.
Duncan is entering the oculus rift,
looking for a girlfriend.
Right?
Is that what you're doing in there?
Put that thing on for two minutes.
I want to vomit.
Nausea,
all my utopian ideas about the
occupants.
Really steroid corrected that they say
the new ones.
There's this,
there's this thing.
It's like latency.
If there's 15 millisecond latency or
some kind of latency between when you
move your head and when it registers
that you've moved your head and it's in
milliseconds and under a certain amount.
Apparently you don't get motion
sickness,
but where my oculus rift is that right
now,
like if I have a drunk friend over and
they put on that rift,
they just turned green.
It doesn't work,
so.
So police could use it as a.
As an alcohol test.
Yeah.
You x could use it if you.
If you're sick of using your finger to
vomit,
just put on the oculus rift and run
around half life for six minutes.
You spew dementia
in films is reproducing American
Werewolf in London.
They're going to reboot.
It has the same story.
I hope it's good,
man.
I hope so.
To leave it alone.
Well,
I just hope they don't go CGI and fuck
it up.
They will.
When?
When did we make that work?
I'm sure there's some,
but it's possible.
That worked with amazing of the body
snatchers.
I remember when they remade Texas
chainsaw massacre.
I didn't want me to call the police.
I watched the second invasion of the
body snatchers last night.
That Donald Sutherland one.
That's the second one I believe.
Yeah,
that's good.
There's one from.
Is that true?
Am I correct?
A black and white was an old black and
white one.
That's right.
You know,
I know it's true because I watched it
actually and it was really fun.
Now that I remember.
Okay.
Because I've seen three of them.
There's a Jennifer Tilly won two are meg
tilly,
tilly one later.
But the uh,
the original one is really fascinating
because it's like a lot like the
twilight zone movie in that it's a time
capsule you would not work today.
It would be a terrible piece of shit
that you wouldn't believe that they
could actually make.
But when you watch it in the context of
it being from like 1951 or whatever the
fuck it was,
it's really interesting.
Oh,
cool.
And ideas.
I mean,
even if the effects are bullshit,
the ideas are timeless,
like old star trek episodes or,
or twilight
zone.
Some of those ideas were just amazing.
Yeah.
Well they ran out of them though.
They used them all up on those fucking,
you know,
all those,
a hitchcock shows and all those,
uh,
those.
What are those?
What was that one show that they had
that um,
fuck night gallery?
Well,
no,
there was,
there was a,
the twilight zone and then there was one
that was like,
it.
God Damn it.
There was another one that was like,
it
love American style.
The love boat.
Now.
There was a similar thing to the
twilight zone,
but I can't remember what it is now.
I thought it was called night gallery.
Might have tales from the crypt.
The outer limits.
Thank you.
Thank you Jamie.
Yeah,
that was it.
The outer limits was another one.
It was very similar along those lines.
They,
those guys burned through so many ideas.
Yeah.
Are there shows like,
is there a show like of ideas there?
There's no more creepy freaky ideas.
There's all kinds of freaky ideas,
man.
I think they get tired.
All this vampire shit and we're wolves
and zombies and vampires for girls to
have.
You know,
it's all about sex.
Empires got so hot.
They weren't always like that.
Lookup nosferatu.
Have you ever seen that?
[inaudible] love it.
That is a vampire.
That thing is scary.
It's got like long,
awful fingers that just just,
it's a terrible being now.
Like these glitter vampires,
the sun doesn't even hurt him.
It just makes him like makes their.
Yeah,
there's not for auto
and by the way,
I look at his teeth.
Very rat.
Like a completely different thing.
Yeah.
He was there with like rats that were
people that would hypnotize people and
suck their blood out.
Ever since you told me,
you pointed out the fact that in
twilight this vampire is hundreds of
years old dating a high school.
Yes.
It's ridiculous.
The idea is ridiculous that he would
first of all have to keep going to high
school.
The idea is that he died when he was 17.
He so cute because he died when he was
17.
He's going to be 17 for perpetuity.
That's preposterous.
That doesn't make any sense.
Like why?
Why doesn't he just go to fucking high
school for the 100th year in a row?
Just keeps giving high school.
Nobody notices the fact that this guy
just fucking hopping around the country,
going to high school after high school,
showing in as the weird loner
that white skin.
But that does happen,
man.
There's that.
You heard the story about the guy who
would pose as a fourth grader.
Did you ever hear that?
Oh my God,
he's like some kind of like a little
person or he's got some kind of aging
thing and you would enroll himself in
elementary schools.
Like there was this guy,
he was an adult who was in an elementary
school for like a year.
It's like mine.
Yeah.
I can't remember his name though,
but it was like he was,
he would just pretend to be a kid,
you know?
And so as an adult,
it's funny.
Uh,
well when I was in New York there was a
girl who was on the Arsenio Hall show.
Okay.
She was a stand up comic and we all knew
her as this young teenage girl from the
East village and she was like 14 or 15
years old and she was going up and doing
standup and she was funny,
man.
She was funny,
like an adult and it was weird.
It was weird watching because as far as
standup comics go,
it wasn't like going to see Dunkin or
Joey Diaz or he wasn't like high level
standup comedy,
but it was impressive for a 15 year old.
So she goes on the Arsenio Hall show and
the fucking had phones light up and
they're like,
I went to high school with this bitch.
She's fucking 30 like she's not in
heights.
She's not 14 the fuck out of.
She graduated in 1986 and people start
going crazy and calling in and she gets,
she gets exposed.
Barry Katz client,
by the way,
when she knew she'd get exposed.
Um,
I don't think she did.
I think she thought she'd get away with
it on TV.
I don't know if she changed her name.
I don't know what she did,
but she went up there.
Don't worry though.
I mean,
what a movie,
you know,
like 30 [inaudible].
She had a 15 year old kid.
I didn't.
Shit like,
that's going to start happening more and
more with the age regression therapies.
They're going to have,
I think there's going to be like this.
Did you hear about that?
The thing that keeps popping up about
the mice,
did you hear about this?
And they're going to start human trials
in a year.
It's some kind of.
They figured out some way to reverse.
Apparently reverse the aging process in
mice.
They want to start human trials in a
year.
I love being around and scientists
because his both.
I know your bullshit fake,
but yeah,
apparently.
I mean,
who knows really?
Yeah.
Where did you read this?
On the Internet?
No,
I think it's real.
I do think it's real,
like it's an actual.
I'm sorry,
but every time I hear this shit,
you know,
ray Kurtzweil is going to die.
I'm really sorry.
And not because some guy shoots him with
a radioactive bullets,
researchers reverse aging process in
mice.
People could be next.
This is in the Huffington Post.
This is in a bunch of science science
journals.
It's all over.
It's about the Mitochondria and it's
about,
um,
uh,
they've figured out a way.
It says,
the age process we discovered is like a
married couple when they're young,
they communicate well,
but over time,
living in close quarters for many years,
communication breaks down.
Harvard University based investigator,
this is all like legit shit.
As with marriage,
the restoring of the lines of
communication can nurse backs cells to
health.
The communication breakdown is caused by
lower levels of the chemical called n a
d,
which decreases with age.
Prior to this study,
the only known ways of slowing the
decreased were to have a low calorie
diet and regular exercise.
In this study,
researchers used to compound that mimics
the benefits of diet and exercise on
mice.
There you go.
Fell off.
Give me a pill.
I'll take it.
In two year old mice,
the compound helped reduce insulin
resistance and inflammation,
making them nearly as healthy as mice
that were just six months old.
It's something like a 60 year old being
similar to a 20 year old
20 year olds.
You're about to be fucked because all
these 50 year olds are going to turn
into 20 year olds.
Again,
you have a mattress on a floor.
You know what I mean?
You're sleeping on a mattress,
you're a d,
you're now competing with people
who should be dead and her health
and why does it have to be competition
and can we all just get along?
Can't we all just work together?
I can't.
This be the ultimate social utopia when
there is no age,
you got to be ageism anymore.
It'd be yourself.
Right?
Because think about it.
The 50 year old women are going to be
like 20 year olds deck.
It's going to be in the game and they're
gonna have,
they're gonna have all the experience of
having had kids and having live Loris
and they're not going to man.
Yeah.
Well no,
but money and I find women,
you know,
45 and over are a lot easier to deal
with a lot easier.
Do you think they're just more
realistic?
More relaxed?
Yeah.
They're not like living in that hallmark
bullshit world anymore of expected
standards that you're trying to say.
Chris Ryan there,
they've got experience.
They lower their standards,
their,
they don't expect a lot from you.
They're not looking for six pack
anymore.
They just,
okay,
we just sit down.
Can we just watch TV?
We just have a dream.
We'd have to walk.
I look forward to the future,
man.
I that I comments saw exciting to see
that kind of research star start popping
up because if that's popping up that you
know,
six more things based on it that are
going to pop up and,
and it's,
it's a really cool thing.
They did say that.
Sorry,
go ahead.
They said that the cost of the treatment
course is,
would be insane,
like hundreds of thousands of dollars as
was when you bought a cell phone,
the first cell phone for thousands of
dollars and now you can go to Bolivia.
In the middle of the jungle,
people have cell phones.
There's also this artificial muscle that
they've created that has 1000 times
human strength.
This is another story that came out
today or yesterday.
Rather.
American scientists have developed a
robotic muscle 1000 times more powerful
than humans using a revolution.
It using a revolutionary material that
fluidly cer changes its properties.
I want to.
That means the invention gives vanadium
dioxide amazing superhero style powers.
It's most striking properties to change
shape,
and structure whenever differing amounts
of heat or applied to it.
We are in for some really freaky shit in
the next couple of decades.
Things are going to get really,
really weird because no one saw this
coming years.
Things always getting really weird.
Always have been the weirdest times ever
are always right now.
Yeah.
I mean I feel like a curmudgeon,
but.
But you guys talking about reversing the
aging process and the super muscle and
you know,
this and that.
I feel like Mark Twain,
you know,
when they invented the radio and he's
like,
oh great,
we still don't have anything to say to
each other.
You know?
It's like,
do we not know?
I mean,
I'm talking about in his time.
The point is,
sounds like you had a hangover when he
said Mark Twain,
I feel like we're going in the wrong
direction.
And so every time there's another carrot
dangling out there saying,
oh look,
you're eternal life.
Oh look,
there's this all.
You're going to a super hero.
It's,
it's like the casino guy.
We're almost out of money in the casinos
guys saying,
well maybe if you just place a few more
beds,
you know,
you'll win it all back.
But again,
it hasn't always been the case though.
Everybody always thought that the.
You ever listened to a hunter s Thompson
talking in the 19 seventies.
This is,
it's over.
It's almost over.
The fucking great demise were,
were,
were skidding into the,
to the apocalypse.
Everybody's felt that way was right.
But he was he still here?
Look what are we?
We're here.
He's not shit's well,
he shot himself in the head,
but shit shit is always weird
by the way.
Cut It.
Three years from now,
Chris Ryan's going to be 21 and I'll
shoot myself in the head and you're
going to be healthy every day.
Finally banging it.
Twenty year old.
Yeah.
You give up on those 45 year olds and a
fucking so needy cats.
Yeah.
I,
I don't know man.
I mean you can like philosophically
break it down as much as possible.
If it's going to give me a pill that's
going to or not,
that's the thing.
They're just going to tell you they will
to keep you in the game,
keep you running.
What are you talking about?
Well,
what about.
I mean,
I mean you said like everything's always
about to end,
right,
but on the alternatively everything's
always about to be great.
I mean,
in the thirties and forties they were
saying,
oh,
what are we gonna do with all our
leisure time?
The technology is going to give us.
We're going to be working three hours a
week and have jet packs and you know,
have her food grow out of the table just
as we're ready to eat it.
None of that shit ever happens.
It never happens.
We're working more hours now than we
were then.
Those standard of living,
you know,
we're talking about hunter s Thompson in
the seventies.
The middle class family now has less
money than they had in 1970.
Right?
At least they're not dying of
tuberculosis of a,
you know,
insulin resistance and that over
coughing,
like spraying blood into my kerchief and
watching everyone around me wigs are
coming.
You're really making a big,
big,
big leap because I don't think it's that
black and white.
I don't.
I don't think that it really is worse.
I don't think that.
I think it's gotten way better.
I think for sure.
Yeah.
Quality of life is still.
There's just too many people,
a finite amount of resources,
corrupt economy beyond corrupt
government.
All those excel good games for x,
but what about all this stuff that we
said earlier?
What about all this stuff we said about
communication,
about the access to information being
different than it's ever been before.
I think if anything,
it's more rosy today.
The view of society and the potential
for the future more rosy today than it's
ever been before.
The Syria thing is a perfect example.
This is the first time in my
recollection,
my recollection that the United States
people,
the populace stood up when there was a
proposed military action and said fuck
that,
like a giant percentage of the
population was so alarmed that these
knuckleheads we were in,
they were like,
hey guys,
this is revolution type shit.
Like if you go through with this,
this is your.
At the door of a revolution,
and here's the best
way to keep this revolution from
happening.
Keep them calm and the best way to keep
them comms and not go into another world
right now.
You guys are running to shell games
You're sucking minerals out of
Afghanistan.
You sucking oil out of Iraq.
How would everybody just back the fuck
off and stop trying to invade everything
all at once and they did and that was a
sign of progress.
I see that as a sign of like so much
blood has already been lost.
The body can't bleed anymore.
And once a half full guy exhaustion,
the country's exhausted,
broke and people are saying,
you know,
we can't do anymore.
We get the national guard doing seven
tours in Iraq.
You know,
the national guard never went anywhere
overseas until Bush and now we've
accepted that as normal.
We've got higher percentage of people in
prisons than any country in the world
than this country ever has before.
Doubt,
you know,
it's like I,
I think going back to my friend that I
was talking about earlier in Africa,
it might be a wash,
it might be the,
yeah,
the Internet is really cool and that's
it,
but on the other hand,
the prison industrial complex is,
you know,
and yeah,
it might be cool that we didn't get into
Syria,
but on the other hand were blown up
wedding parties in Yemen from the sky
and nobody gives a shit because nobody's
dying on our side.
And you know what I mean?
It's like maybe it's a wash,
but when people start telling me utopia
is right around the corner,
my bullshit detector start blinking
really rightly.
I don't necessarily take you Topia,
but terminal life,
super muscles,
whatever.
It's a sales pitch.
Oh,
I don't agree for something that isn't
gonna pay off,
but I don't agree because I,
I think if you just look at what we
have,
I mean we already have superpowers.
You have God goddamn phone and you can
talk to and it answers anyways,
but are people happier?
Are People really happier now than they
were 50 years ago?
Some are,
some are happy,
some I don't think you could ever say
that are people happier because if
you're just going to generalize about
just people overall,
well,
what kind of people we talking about?
Well,
you have to take an aggregate.
We're talking about people in America.
That's exactly right.
People in Nice neighborhoods,
we were talking about people in poverty
is in progress,
but if we're talking about progress for
the human race or human species than we
are talking about all people.
We've got to be talking about the
aggregate,
right?
Jesus Christ.
Isn't that what progress would be?
Well,
we don't have.
I mean you have influence on your.
Your immediate environment.
You have influence on the people that
you're allowed to reach outside your
immediate environment with technology,
but once you start talking about the
entire world,
if we're really responsible for that,
well then all societies have to break
down and we have to start from scratch.
I'm not saying we're responsible,
I'm just saying that when people start
talking about how things are getting
better,
I think you need to.
What we need to do is understand,
define our terms.
What do you mean by better a and
secondly,
what do you mean by for us?
I'll tell you better.
Here's better for me.
I can go on audible.com,
download an audio book of Jack Kornfield
talking about describing Buddhism.
This super simple way that I've never
heard it.
Like,
oh,
wakes me up to this idea of like,
Shit,
man,
I get it.
I've got to like if I don't love myself,
if I don't figure out a way to to to to
really embrace myself,
I'm going to be
a miserable,
are going to be kind of unhappy.
I'm going to be unhappy for the rest of
my life.
So are things are getting better because
we have access to information that can
improve our internal states and then
once you're happy,
all the innovation can be enjoyed,
but if you're.
If you,
if you.
If so,
I'm saying that the access to
information now is so much greater than
it ever was.
That if somebody really wants to plug in
and transform themselves,
they can and that's better.
That's better.
But another point is,
in Buddhism,
there's an idea of something called
fundamental dissatisfaction,
which comes from being a human being,
and it doesn't matter what time you were
born into,
it doesn't matter where you were born or
if you're born in a futuristic society
where,
uh,
you never will age and flying android,
blowjob machines come down the moment
they detect any type of horniness from
your neural patterns and,
and make you come.
You're still,
if you don't deal with your internal,
if you don't deal with the,
the,
the basic,
fundamental problem of being a human
being,
the idea that life is suffering.
If you don't deal with your attachment
to,
uh,
to your ego and your identity,
you're going to suffer no matter what.
And that doesn't change.
That's just part of being a human being.
So,
I mean,
I just think it's more interesting time,
better lotions,
more interesting.
Cars go faster,
zero to 60 times a down.
Yeah.
Um,
I think the potential for expansion is
monstrous.
And I think that the the potential for
information to get to you,
the possibilities of it getting to or
greater than it's ever been before,
the access to knowledge is insane.
And putting it all together and making a
package as a happy human being is always
a difficult pursuit.
Always will be even more complicated now
because there's an increasing amount of
variables and it staggeringly increased
amount of variable and you can only.
I mean there are two things.
There's a bottleneck.
Like you say,
there's more information than ever
before and I completely agree with that,
but your brain still has to processes
and they can only go a certain speed.
Well that's where the shit like this
terminator star muscle comes in because
it's gonna,
they're gonna move into the neuro field,
they're going to implant muscles and no,
they're saying they're able to create an
artificial style muscle that place your
muscles.
They're implying,
well,
this is a.
This is the very early stages of
anything that would apply to a robot or
to whatever the fuck they're going to
do.
But essentially they're trying to mimic
what the possibilities of muscle tissue.
You know,
there's another one that I've done where
they combined spider silk with human
human skin to create some artificial
bulletproof skin.
Spiderman today,
they just these.
It's fascinating to watch people break
down the very structure of reality.
They're very compounds of the various
aspects of life,
whether it's flesh or bone or cognitive
function.
The brain itself,
they've created artificial brain cells.
I mean there are like literally miss
things or materializing and it's going
to be any credible puzzle that we have
to solve as far as our possibilities for
altering our environment.
But none of it matters if we're not
getting information about government,
about the inner workings of corporations
and because these are the people.
Those are the institutions that unless
we're not getting more,
we're not our access to good information
about,
about what's really going on is
destroyed by the Internet because the
Internet has killed journalism sort of,
but isn't the real problem with all
these.
Whether it's corporations that give
money to lobbyists that give money to
politicians and influence isn't.
The real problem is that it's not clear
and obvious what's going on.
People are slowly starting to unveil all
these issues of corruption.
Well,
as the boundaries between people in
information becomes smaller and smaller
to the point where there's no boundary.
If everyone's going to be accountable,
you're going to be accountable for
everything,
including corporations.
Corporations are going to be accountable
for their actions.
Who's but who's going to do that work?
Who's going to go to the board meetings
and record who voted for what and where
the money's going.
That's journalism.
That's if you,
and there's no money in journals.
If you live today in this world,
that is the case.
I think the world where we live in in
20,
30,
40,
whatever it is,
there's gonna be no secrets.
It's not going to be like the board has
to meet.
Everyone's going to know in the on the
whole planet what the corporation's been
up to,
what the ramifications of this,
who's profited from this directly and
the Bradley Manning's are going to win
out over the NSA percent for life.
Yeah,
Greenwald.
I just listened to him on the way over
here.
I was listening to him,
he was talking,
he was at Marxism conference or
something and he was talking about how
he was on meet the press and how David
Gregory essentially called for him to be
arrested and put in prison for being a
journalist.
Unbelievable.
You know,
and David Gregory himself is completely
complicit in,
in selectively using the leaks that are
given to him.
Right.
Which is what he was accusing Greenwald
of having done,
you know,
utilize a leak and writing your story.
And he's like,
that's what David does every week,
you know,
at some dinner party,
somebody mentioned something to him that
they want to be disseminated.
That's all those guys do.
And he described them as actors playing
journalists on TV.
But I mean going Greenwald's one of the
only ones out there,
you know,
Jeremy Scahill I
see.
I don't think the Internet is destroyed.
Journalism journalism destroyed itself.
The Internet has created real journalism
and the Internet has given birth to a
totally new style of journalism that's
not connected to the machine that's
actually viewer supported.
Whether it's shows like the young Turks
or podcasts or anything,
what you're getting is a viewer
supported experience where there's no
incentive to lie to you anymore.
The incentive is actually to tell the
truth.
These shifts are you can't ignore them
and there's this new access and this new
thirst for information.
It's very different than anything any
culture has ever experienced before.
I don't think you could take it lightly
and I think.
I think ultimately it spells progress
because it spells outrage and outrage
over corruption.
Once there's a balance,
there's a yin and a Yang when it comes
to government and once there's a balance
in the corruption has been least forced
to relinquish its grasp.
Whether prosecuted,
whether people will go to have to go to
jail for the way they've been running
this society is debatable.
You know,
this is what the law used to be at a
certain point in time.
Yeah.
None of this torture guys are anywhere
near a jail,
but there's no debate that it's got all
stop.
Whether whether it comes from that,
whether it comes from.
There was a recent story about how the
drug war is a complete and total fucking
joke based on the fact that these banks
that have been caught laundering money.
Did you read this in Florida?
UBC?
Billions of dollars.
Yeah.
Unbelievable.
I'll,
I'll pull it up because it's such a
fucking crazy,
crazy story,
but when you,
when you read it,
it just,
it shows you that the idea of a drug
war,
of the fact that they're trying to stop
drugs from coming in nonsense.
They're just trying to arrest black
people.
They're trying to fill up jails.
They trying to make it so that the
people who are in control of the
distribution stay in control of the
distribution.
It's madness.
Yeah.
I always feel like I'm raining on the
parade when I talked to you two guys
because you're so hopeful for the
future.
I think you,
you're,
you've just seen more than we have.
You've been to more places to see me or
fuck and educated.
I love it.
It's so great,
man,
because like it's so you need that.
You need balance.
It's good to have balance,
man.
You don't want an echo chamber,
you need somebody who's going to throw
out the facts and [inaudible] in that
process.
Maybe you'll,
you know,
obviously,
are we headed towards some utopian
reality or some Utopian future?
I'd say the odds of that are pretty
slim.
Um,
especially,
uh,
as long as people are caught up in
themselves as an individual instead of
recognizing they're part of a whole,
uh,
regardless of any kind of innovation,
there's going to,
that's always going to create problems.
But I do think there's some beautiful
things on the horizon that are just
going to be wonderful.
Of course,
throw the thing of these conversations
get complicated because anyone I'm
talking to always says something like,
oh,
I don't want to have tuberculosis,
or there are good things on the horizon.
That's all true.
What I'm talking about right
is,
is the general trajectory of our species
trip through time going in a good
direction or a bad director?
Let me tell you before anybody.
Uh,
Oh,
the rolling stone article is a
outrageous SBC.
HSBC settlement proves that the drug war
is a joke.
It's by Matt Matt Taibbi.
He's fantastic.
The Best Thompson even better because
he's more prolific and he's not fucked
up on meth.
My title.
Oh,
you gotta read my greatest journalists
of all time.
That octopus thing reminded
me of him because he's famous for the
octopus squid.
Yeah.
What I was gonna say is that in my world
it's better.
So if you're saying this society better,
well I only as applied,
you know,
but in my world,
100 percent.
But look,
look at us.
We're three guys dudes,
you know,
with three beautiful muscular men,
magical white people were magical way.
People with no job,
right?
None of us is punching a clock anywhere.
A lot of the people who are listening to
this or sitting in a cubicle somewhere
and they're working 40,
50 hours a week,
they get home,
they're fucking exhausted.
They don't have time to read Matt Taibbi
because they got to like change the
diapers and the kid and take the other
one to soccer and you know,
pay the alimony and it's like,
I think it's really important that we
don't have.
We don't forget how incredibly fortunate
we are and what an amazing pinnacle we
happen to be standing on looking at
experience that said,
you figured it out,
you figured it out.
I figured it out.
Here we are in our world.
The world is better today,
or we're just really lucky.
Or we're living.
I don't know.
I don't know what we figured out.
Why can't we embrace the simulation
theory that this simulation that we have
all subscribed to.
We jumped into a really good simulation.
We don't have jobs and uh,
like the world is a Goddamn Hologram.
It's been proven that.
Yeah,
that was last week,
right?
The hologram.
The universe is a Hologram Dunkin.
Some is something at the retreat they
said that they were talking about this
thing broke you.
I loved it.
Here's something they said I really
like,
which is because it's this thing that
you're doing the starving African child
thing where it's like there's always
this starving African child to think
about when you're too happy.
And the thing is,
if you really want to honor and respect
the suffering of the world and people
who are trapped in various predicaments,
the greatest thing you could do is not
feel guilty about your own happiness
ride.
That shit.
I don't feel guilty about it.
Guilt to me.
I mean,
you know,
Chogyam Trungpa,
right?
Okay.
One of the things that guy,
who the fuck are you talking to me about
trump,
is that he was a.
He was a Tibetan Guru who came to the US
early and
in a past state.
He was a Tibetan.
He was like a,
a reincarnation who came to the United
States,
started wearing suits,
drinking,
humping girls in his,
in his Buddhism is breakdown of Buddhism
is amazing.
He's got two great books that I know of
cutting through spiritual materialism.
What's the war?
The warrior thing,
the path of the Shambala,
the warrior,
and another beautiful.
Yeah.
My children as a teacher who was his
disciple,
there's a great documentary on Netflix
about them that you can watch with
years.
This guy from,
he's from,
I guess the sixth,
67th,
but he died from liver disease,
from drinking.
He was a like Alan Watts who also died
from liver disease,
died from liver disease too.
That's so sad.
But,
but he,
his whole thing was like,
just be be who you are,
like who you are like
to do to really love booze.
He did and he would like,
like there's a story which is.
Anyway,
he liked playing with people's
conception of how he should be and like
in this documentary there's a story
where he's onstage with some,
like very like,
you know,
a tight square spiritual teacher and
he's onstage with a spiritual teacher
and he's wasted.
He's acting drunk and he's wasted.
And like after the talk,
he's in the hallway walking with some of
his disciples,
totally not drunk anymore.
He's like,
how did I do?
What do you think?
He was acting drunk.
He was doing this because he was fucking
around with like,
he was trying to create a contrast
between this guy who apparently like
considered himself to be a very buttoned
up,
very spiritual spiritual man and him.
It was just like,
look,
I can do whatever I want.
I can be whoever I want to be.
I don't have to act like I'm holy or
sacred,
you know?
I don't have to act like a spiritual
person.
I can be a drunk guy who humps hippies
and still be a spiritual teacher and
still have something to offer the world.
That's a beautiful thing,
man.
It is a beautiful thing except that he's
pretending to be drunk.
I never side with the people that are
I always suspect foul play.
You're pretending to be drunk.
Why would you pretend to be drunk or
pretend to be anything else?
Why your documentary?
I don't know if you've ever seen comics
that get like a shot of water and
pretend it's Tequila onstage now.
It's dark,
it's dark.
They fake drunk.
They fake pretending to be drunk.
Well,
he's think wasn't.
I don't think anyway,
I can't defend it because attack is.
Fuck.
I can't do.
It wasn't when he did it.
Maybe he was one of the first.
He wasn't at the fucking Improv.
Well,
Dean Martin,
but it mean seriously.
What is he doing?
He's faking it.
He was doing,
but it was.
Listen,
I'm.
First of all,
I'm not a disciple of Chogyam Trungpa,
so I don't know why I'm getting
defensive.
Alan Watts anyway.
No,
no.
Chogyam Trungpa.
Oh,
he's the one who did that?
Drunk.
I got confused.
Well,
either one.
Why did the guy do that?
I think he was demonstrating the power
of not giving a shit,
which is one of my pet theories.
Recently.
I think it's the only power we get that
that actually becomes stronger as we
age,
but how you guys not giving a shit if
he's pretending to be drunk.
He obviously gives a shit.
I think I.
I'm going to say he had on show.
No,
he doesn't give a shit about his
reputation as a spiritual guru,
so he's making a fool of himself
intentionally to demonstrate the fact
that he's no big deal.
A lot of these gurus,
that's what they do,
man.
That's part of what they do is they get
around people and they do some
incredibly untraditional,
weird thing that doesn't seem to make
much sense or really like affects the
people who watch them and it usually is
a way to like point out you're your own
like ego and you're where you're stuck.
That's the idea and you have to.
It's a leap of faith.
Like was Chogyam Trungpa doing that on
purpose?
Maybe he was really drunk.
Maybe you just wasn't having a good
night or maybe he wasn't doing it
because he had a weird sense of humor.
Who knows?
But all you can say is this guy put out
some amazing fucking books that really
break down Tibetan Buddhism and also
like some of his disciples,
like children,
they're amazing teachers and they asked
her about him,
you know,
what did she think about him being a
boozer drinking and she's just like,
what can I say?
He was a great teacher and he taught me
the Dharma.
He taught me Buddhism,
so like,
how can I judge?
I don't know.
That's just what he was like.
It's really cool,
man.
There's a,
there's a,
especially in Tibet and Buddhism,
one of the progenitors of it was a t
Lopa was his name and this was a,
you know,
they would go out and try to gather
information about Buddhism.
And so this guy,
I think his name was Marva,
is that right?
Mark Miller.
Miller Miller up.
Not really.
I don't know if there's very rapey.
I don't know if you had EPA.
Yeah,
Milarapa.
Reva.
He was like wandering to try to gather
information about Buddhism and uh,
he,
you know,
he kept asking who can teach me this?
You can give me,
you can really teach me about this.
And so they told him where there's this
guy,
he lopa in this fishing village,
you can go there and talk to him.
He's a,
he's an awakened being.
And so he gets there and he like,
as people do you know if this st t dot
Lopa this enlightened being and they're
like,
we know that the filthy homeless guy who
lives down by the river and eats fish
scraps,
is that who you want to find any?
And he goes to this guy and the guy
proceeds to torture him for years,
years and years,
and like finally at the end of this
whole process,
and there's all these stories about the
various means that this guy used to
teach him the final transmission.
He slapped him in the face with the
Sandal and that was like the big
download that he got.
And so the whole point of it all this
mythology or half mythology or whatever
it is,
is that if you let your ego decide what
a teacher is going to look like,
then you are not going to see a real
teacher when they cross your path
because you've already decided they wear
robes or they don't wear robes or
they're in shape or they're not in shape
or they're this or they're that.
The moment you do that,
you've cut out so much in the world and
that's what's really cool about a
Buddhism and all these stories is that
quite often the teacher was never who
you expected it to be.
It was always a person who went way,
way against what you thought.
Somebody who was awake in might be like,
and there's something really beautiful
about that because if you knew what
awakened beings look like,
then you would be awakened yourself,
wouldn't you?
And you wouldn't really need anything
because you already have it all figured
out.
So awakened being slapped in the face
with the Sandal,
awakened beings,
awakened beings apparently do whatever
it takes to,
to wake up the other beings around them.
And that's the essence of a Koan.
Right?
All this.
What's the hand one answer?
Slapping one sandal.
Slough it.
So yeah,
you remind me of this German guy I met
in India,
uh,
years ago.
I just met him in a cafe.
Just some guy had been living in India
for a long time and we were getting
drunk and he told me this story when he
was young and first arrived in India.
He found his teacher who didn't speak
any German or English.
Right?
But he just saw this guy in Varanasi and
he was like,
that's the guy that's the guy who's
going to teach me.
And he started following this guy and
the guy for weeks and the guy was just
like,
who are you?
Get away from me,
why are you following me?
And he just followed this guy all
through India.
And then finally like he was washing his
robes and he fucked up the robe somehow
in the wash.
And so then this guru had like weird
robes that weren't the right color.
And he then eventually he let this
German guy wear a robe and the German
guys sort of ingratiated just like a
stray dog won't leave you alone.
And he never understood what the guy was
saying.
He just felt there was something in his
eyes that would be transmitted to him if
he stuck with him.
And eventually because the white guy was
following him all around,
this guru became really well known in
India.
Right?
And he started bringing the white guy up
next to him on the stage when he was
doing his teachings and stuff,
because everybody knew him is the guru
that the white dude follow it all
around.
And eventually as the German language
skills got better in Hindi or whatever
language the,
the guy was speaking,
the German realized that this was
completely full of shit and he was just
like using him to car.
So it,
it was what you were saying reminded me
of it.
This whole idea of like what a teacher
looks like and it's A.
Yeah.
The idea is it's like the teacher,
the idea is you already are inside.
You already awake,
you have this,
you're,
you're caught up in your ego,
you're attached to your ego,
you're already awake.
And so different people,
they need excuses to wake up.
They need,
they need an excuse,
they need some kind of things.
Some people need to wear robes or some
people need some kind of intense
meditation practice in some stories and
Buddhism,
somebody sees like a drop of a water,
hit a puddle and suddenly they,
they gained the transmission and wake
up.
But uh,
and I think Chogyam Trungpa,
he even said this whole process of
initiation is kind of ridiculous.
It's really more of a thing for you.
It's more of a thing because you need
the excuse to be a better person.
This is actually not to get too far off
track here,
but this is in the brothers Karamazov
dust.
They ask.
He talks about Paul,
who is the basically the,
the,
the father of Christianity who never
even met Jesus,
but he was like walking down the use of
persecute Christians and his name was
Saul and he was walking on the road to
Damascus and Jesus appears to him and
says,
Saul,
why do you persecute me?
And at that moment he like he,
he changed.
He realizes that Jesus is love and he
becomes like a disciple of Christ and he
changes and so Dostoevsky and is
awesome.
I say in the brothers,
Karamazov says,
okay,
what happened there is Jesus like a
magical medicine being that like touched
him and there was some magical thing
that went through him were suddenly got
better.
If that's the case,
then Jesus has nothing and humans are
just empty robotic things and there's no
freedom.
All you have to do is come in contact
with the right person and you're going
to get better again.
Freedom's gone in that equation.
Or did saul need an excuse to stop being
an asshole and the excuse he used was
this hallucination of some magical being
that came to him and he let that be the
excuse that let him truly become a a,
a,
an awakened being,
and this is why in so many different
religions and so many different
philosophies,
there's the process of initiation which
is like these series of things that you
go through to the martial arts.
Yeah.
It's funny because your,
your thoughts are all the.
All the things you're saying are all
very beautiful,
but they're there.
They're so clearly a work of fiction
there,
so clearly pros there.
So clearly a story like all the even
there like flavored.
It's like there's truth in them,
but it's truth delivered in the filter
of a story.
You know about someone getting slapped
in the face of the Sandal and beginning
enlightened or someone seeing water hit.
It doesn't make it untrue.
No,
no,
definitely not.
Especially when you consider the age of
these things,
right?
The age of these initial thoughts.
I mean,
how old are the original stories that
goddamn ancient knows
mean?
Isn't that the essence of fiction to
convey a truth?
I find it fascinating because of the
fact that when these things were
originally conveyed and put down onto
some form of written language or what
have you,
the the,
the actual stories still resonate
through the obvious fiction,
actual truths of what you're saying.
Still resonate through the obvious
fiction of the work.
Like you can tell me that a guy slapped
a guy with a Sandal and he achieved
enlightenment.
I'm sure he did.
Well,
no,
but I mean,
but what you're saying behind it that
you know,
what you're doing is exposing someone to
these various new passive thinking that
sometimes a simple thing like water
splashing into a pond but opens up the
doors of perception in a strange way
that allows this sort of exponentially
increasing understanding of your reality
and then it is just one event that
causes this.
It is really a slap in the face of the
Sandal,
but it's still obviously fiction.
Well,
and it's what we were talking about
before we went on air placebo.
Yes,
right.
The fact that a placebo isn't an actual
drug doesn't mean it's less real if its
effects are tangible.
Well,
yeah,
but it's such a weird fucking thing.
I don't think it's just placebo.
I think you're talking about a container
to hold a certain type of energy.
That's what a placebo is.
Placebo triggers yourself healing
potential.
That was always his religion.
Religion gives you a structure within
which to be the decent person you
already were.
Yeah.
The one of the most ultimately
fascinating things about human beings is
the placebo effect.
The idea that there's a tangible,
quantifiable result that comes from a
certain type of thinking,
but whether it's positive or negative or
you know,
or stress,
just stress like they've shown that
people that live in big cities or people
that have high stress jobs,
just much more likely to have a host of
different things go wrong with their
body because they're just fucking red
line and get all the
stressed devastating to your immune
system.
I spoke at a scientific conference once,
a psycho neuro immunology.
Do you know about that?
It's essentially the,
the measure of how our mental state or a
psychological state affects our immune
response.
And one of the guys who was onstage with
me is Robert Ader who just died
recently.
He's the first person to ever
demonstrate in a laboratory that,
uh,
you,
if you stress out mice,
their immune system drops.
It was very interesting the way he did
it.
He gave them a,
what's that artificial sweetener?
Aspartame before Xylitol.
Now,
before the first one,
I'm Saccharin Saccharin.
Yeah.
So he put Saccharin in the water and let
them drink the Saccharin.
And as soon as they drank the Saccharin,
he shocked them and so he paired
saccharin with an electrical shock,
right.
And then,
and every time they were shocked,
they're immune response dropped because
they were super stressed and you know,
the release of toxic chemicals and all
that.
And then later,
so he trained them to associate those
two things.
And then later he only gave them
Saccharin and noted that they had the
same response.
So the immune response had been trained.
Ah,
that is fucking hard.
It's so hard though to keep your head
about you.
It's so hard to stay calm,
to just be cool and chill about things.
And then.
Sorry to interrupt you,
but just a.
The really weird thing about this is the
next generation and the third generation
have the same response woe without ever
having.
Exactly.
Wow.
Well that makes sense.
It's like the same thing of the reason
why we have this fear of snakes.
There's a genetic memory that gets
passed down,
but see genessee,
this is where it's really interesting.
This is considered epigenetics because
it's not actually in the DNA,
but it somehow the DNA gets trained by
the experience and that's passed along,
but it's in the DNA gets in the dammit.
Yeah.
See,
that's the thing about DNA.
We've got all these genes,
but it's not if you just have the gene
for this or that.
It's if that gene is triggered.
So there are triggering mechanisms that
are,
are more easily shifted.
Then the genetic content itself.
So it's,
it's you know,
it's like there's a gun,
but that doesn't mean anyone gets shot
unless somebody pulls the trigger.
So the genes are all potentially there,
but some get triggered,
some don't.
And so what seems to happen in this new
field of epigenetics is there they're
noticing that the experience of an
organism somehow affects the expression
of genes in subsequent generations.
Sheldrake's morphogenetic field
addresses this because I don't know that
he believed that it's a genetic
transmission,
but he believes that when a thing
starts,
a new behavior or learns a new thing,
it creates this like a shift in the
morphic field,
some kind of,
some kind of field that exists outside
of like a life and they,
they,
the,
the
uh,
being like genetically like resonates
with that field.
And so when there is some behavior
pattern,
it gets sort of imprinted or it creates
like a,
I can't remember the term,
he is like a Ronnell.
They have some psychedelic language for
it,
but a path in this morphic field that
then every other thing like it begins to
resonate with this shift that it's in
some invisible.
It's like a raindrop going down the
window.
You ever see how they form a path and
then the other ones go into the.
Yeah,
yeah,
that's it.
Yeah,
exactly.
That's exactly right.
Way To put it.
Yeah.
You brought up earlier that I was
skeptical sheldrick.
I'm not skeptical sheldrick.
I'm just not.
I'm not convinced that he's right
either.
I'm just open to it,
but I'm skeptical of it because I want
it to be true and usually stuff that I
want to be true.
It's like,
well,
I don't think he's ever proven anything
to be true.
Like I think his.
His studies on dogs,
no masters or coming home.
How sketchy or those.
I don't think they've been replicated
anywhere.
Yeah,
I'm in the same boat as Stanley who you
met and maybe Dunkin's.
Ketamine is an old friend of sheldrake's
and he's where you are.
He's like,
I don't know.
Maybe he's right.
Maybe he's wrong,
but he hasn't proven anything until he
proves it.
You have to.
You have to say,
hey,
you can't keep writing that.
You know,
you can't keep saying that.
It's A.
It's a fascinating theory,
but to say that you've actually proven
in studies not so much,
you know,
because that would be something like,
look,
they have proven weird shit man.
They've proven that you can teach a rat
how to get through a maze in one part of
the world than a rat in another part of
the world and get through that maze
quicker.
That has been proven.
That's weird.
That's it.
It is.
That's Rupert sheldrake.
Hundreds a month.
Anything that's bullshit that never
happened.
Yeah.
One of my placements for people don't
know what it is.
The 100th monkey was a,
what?
There were two islands.
There are a bunch of monkeys on the two
islands.
They had no contact with each other
because they couldn't swim across the
monkeys.
Don't swim by the way,
but even if they did,
they couldn't have swum across the gulf
between the two islands and tourists
started going to one island,
uh,
and they were both islands and they
throw potatoes this in Japan,
I believe,
and they threw potatoes and the monkeys
on one island learn to use the seawater
to wipe off the dirt off the potatoes.
And then that trend that sort of got
transmitted through all the different
monkeys on the island.
And when the hundredth monkey learned
that trick,
suddenly the monkeys on the other island
started doing it.
It's horseshit.
It jumped.
It's not true.
Yeah.
It says it online that it's bullshit.
Actually in wikipedia.
It's also,
um,
uh,
what they would,
they basically broke down was that the
claim was that it was an observation of
these Japanese scientists,
one of the primary factors and spreading
this claim was that many of the authors
quote secondary,
tertiary,
or post tertiary sources who have
themselves misrepresented the original
observations.
So it's one of those things where it
just becomes this app,
like how many times have you ever heard
people say that?
Um,
there's killer's sperm that attack other
people.
Baker and bellis research.
Yeah.
Not really.
No.
There's no proof whatsoever that sperm
does anything other than sperm stuff.
I never heard.
Firms aren't murderers,
sperm attack on other people's parents.
There has never been proven to be true,
but sperm wars.
But I saw someone on like a science show
the other day quoting that,
that very thing.
And people were fascinated like,
wow,
amazing.
Well,
there.
But there is,
there is some differentiation in semen.
The first spurt of ejaculate is
different from the middle spurt and the
last bird tastes better.
It's true where the tank comes to fruit
toast,
pineapple,
but you know,
you were talking earlier about kill
other sperm,
right?
Well,
yeah,
I mean it's,
it's not that there are sperm that are
killing other sperm that's not the
killer sperm thing and the kamikaze
sperm and all the baker and bellis went
way too far.
In fact they split at that point and the
one of them stopped working with the
other because the one kept saying,
you know,
attack sperm and all this,
but it's true that the first part of the
Jack Hewlett has chemicals that kill
preexisting sperm and the last spurt of
the ejaculate has chemicals that protect
your sperm from the next guy's first
spurt.
So it's like a train,
like the first car on the train attacks
what's already there.
The last car protects what you're
putting there.
Okay.
So he just basically extrapolated way to
is actually interesting.
Right,
exactly.
It's interesting is actually head of the
penis design to suction out other dudes.
Just the plunger that the helmet,
the whole idea of the helmet is the
pushrod and pulls back.
All the other guys just squirts in your
own boys.
Give 'em hell sending your own troop.
It's true.
I mean,
we're obviously designed for multiple
meeting.
I mean that's.
You know,
our testicle swell.
When there's women around that are
having sex with more than one.
The fact that they're outside our
bodies,
right about.
That's about keeping them cooler than
body temperature so that they can be out
rubbing them,
sucking them a lot of the things that
would be useless if they're inside your
body.
It's a Yin and Yang.
You take the possibility of getting
kicked in the balls and you bounce it
against someone's sucking your balls
with a jerk.
You off.
Gorillas have their testicles inside
their body that's also have a little one
inch Dick.
Little one inch sticks.
That's right.
Fucking silly with Ted would not let me
show.
I did my ted talk.
They pulled that I've got in my talk.
I've given all over the place.
There's the sort of last moment,
the pivot of the whole talk is this
slide where I've been showing charts of
testicle size and penis design and all
this stuff,
and then I get to this chart and it's
got and the.
Let's see in the upper left hand corner,
it's got a gorilla lying on his back and
there's no balls and in the upper right
hand corner it's got a Banaba whose
balls are like bigger than chicken eggs
and in the middle it's got a friend of
mine in a hammock wearing a speedo and
it says gorilla Bonobo,
Italian and my friends completely cool
with me using the slide and he says,
he saw I did it in Australia and he saw
it online and wrote to me.
It was really fun.
But anyway.
Oh,
and I did Ted the last rehearsal,
the day before I go on,
they said,
ah,
that one slide.
It's a little creepy and they've already
seen it.
I've already done it in three
rehearsals.
They saw before they even invited me and
they're like,
well,
yeah.
It goes,
it's an one.
One of the people said,
I'm afraid of Italians will be offended.
I'm saying Italians have big balls.
That is not an insult.
You know?
Italians think they're going to be
offended.
What I said.
I said,
have you ever been to New York?
It's weirdly probably ride noisy
motorcycles.
What do you think?
So would they have like a little skull
cap on handlebars?
They hold up like this.
Sorry.
No,
what's the connection?
I didn't get that because they have tiny
dicks,
crazy loud motorcycles to compensate or
they're expensive red sports cars or
they work out a lot.
One of the other.
Well they definitely work out a lot.
Look at the size of gorillas.
Yeah,
like they're working out animals ever.
They're the biggest muscled ones and
they also have the littlest Dick's
there.
Any incidents?
I don't think so.
Well,
Ted,
I love the Ted talks.
I think they're endlessly educational
and fascinating and interesting,
but it's because of the vast amount of
interesting people that they've
collected as an organization.
I've heard a lot of weird shit about
them.
Your thing is one,
Eddie,
Eddie Hong was there with the same thing
with me,
part Graham Hancock horror story,
so they're not infallible and they're
also probably growing at a fucking
staggering Sarah and Sarah Silverman,
Silverman and other things.
In fact,
when I did that and they made me take
the slide,
I went back room to our backstage to the
technical guys,
right?
And one of the guys looked at me.
He said,
you're getting Silverman,
Dick,
you got Silverman.
That's hilarious.
We've got to end this thing.
Fucking pretty goddamn awesome.
Merry Christmas.
Christmas,
Christmas Hagen
Day in the house.
You can see Chris on twitter.
It's Chris Ryan,
p h d and Duncan trussell is of course
Duncan trussell,
two s's,
two l's s t r u s s e l l and download
their podcasts.
You fuck that.
Duncan trussell family hour is
available.
Free and clear on itunes and all other
sources.
And Chris Ryan,
your podcast name and where they can get
it.
Tangentially speaking,
same place.
Nobody could spell that shit and you can
change it to the Chris Ryan show.
I know I can with tangential,
but there you are.
You're going to weed out dummies,
you're gonna.
You're not gonna.
Be able to teach them a tangential
speaking itunes.
It's on itunes or you can get it on
Chris Ryan,
Phd Dot Com and buy the book as well.
Fantastic book sex at dawn.
It'll change your life.
You've already fox.
All right,
we will be back next week with the Great
Roseanne Barr and a bunch of standup
comedians in a bunch of other cool
motherfuckers.
We got a lot of good shit coming up.
If we don't see you a happy holidays.
Enjoy your time with your family.
Enjoy your time with your friends.
Be Joyful,
be loving.
And uh,
we'll see in a few days.
Big Kiss.